foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Shayna China China
of course he has a Chinese bank account
why the [ __ ] wouldn't he
that's all we're gonna hear about the
next two years is laptops and Chinese
bank accounts from Hunter Biden and
today the tax returns have been released
of Donald Trump the last six years
and one of the most notable things all
of a sudden is that he has Chinese bank
accounts hmm
kind of funny don't you think
right-wing trolls are freaking out over
the bidens and Chana Chana Chana Chana
Chana
wonder if it's projection or not hmm
yeah it is now again I have I've told
you this before about the tax returns he
does not give a [ __ ] he doesn't give a
[ __ ] if we know about crime or possible
crime being committed in these tax
returns he does not give a [ __ ]
he does not want you to know that he's
[ __ ] broke and he's not a billionaire
but he's not a successful business
person
his ego is way more important
to him than any kind of criminal
liability
he would much rather be indicted and go
to prison for the rest of his life with
you thinking he's a billionaire than
thinking he's broke okay that is the
most important thing about this all now
I don't know if he's quite freaking out
yet or not let me let me check truth
social
see if Grandpa poopy pants has lost his
mind yet oh yeah in the last 11 minutes
he released a statement
he says here's here's what he says I'll
I'll reads it to you oh [ __ ] he says the
Democrats should have never done it the
Supreme Court should have never approved
it
and it's going to lead to horrible
things for so many people
that's how he starts
oh [ __ ]
that's going to lead to so many horrible
things for so many people in other words
a lot of people are gonna go to prison
because of him
is that what he means I mean I think
that's the truth in it yeah he goes on
to say let's read just a bit more the
great USA
divided will now grow far worse the
radical left Democrats have weaponized
everything
remember this is a dangerous two-way
street
the Trump tax returns once again show
how proudly successful I have been see I
told you I told you it is it is more
about you thinking he's a successful
business person and he's rich
than anything
and how I have been able
to use desperation or how yeah and other
other various other tax deductions as an
incentive for creating thousands of job
and magnets
[Laughter]
thousands of jobs okay you [ __ ] listen
half the time that you hired people to
do anything on your buildings you didn't
even [ __ ] pay them and they went out
of business you are not a job Creator
Trump you were a job Destroyer does
anyone remember 2020 in the aftermath of
the pandemic
great you you left office with less
[ __ ] jobs than you came in with the
only present in modern history to do so
job Cricket get the [ __ ] out of here
with this nonsense should we should we
go on
oh
remember remember I told you that the
Forbes list was a bunch of horseshit you
remember this when Elon wasn't the
richest man in the world anymore and I
told you I told you I said this Forbes
thing is all horseshit you shouldn't
listen to the Forbes list Forbes doesn't
know what they're doing it's all
[ __ ] this is all nonsense
he brings up Forbes I'm not [ __ ] you
in true style he brings up Forbes here
in this statement
Forbes he's quoting from them Trump's
assets are worth an estimate
4.3 billion
the former president owns real stuff
Mansions golf courses Office Buildings
that throw off real cash even if his tax
returns might suggest otherwise the D.C
hotel opened in 2016 and by 2018 Trump
had already declared tax losses of 55.5
million there according to the times
still the property is worth something
one investor offered
175 million for it before the
coronavirus decimated the hotel industry
so clearly again clearly he is broke
listen it doesn't matter what property
you have titled in your business name
it doesn't [ __ ] matter the bank owns
it
the bank owns it you default on the
payment the bank will come and get the
[ __ ] you ever had a car loan you ever
tried to not pay the car loan have you
ever has the bank came and got your car
yeah they will because they own the note
which means they own the property this
is how this [ __ ] works in the
capitalist Society I I really can't
stress this enough that people in this
country do not understand how our system
of government works and how our system
of finances work now these tax returns
are very complicated they're very
complicated and the reason why they're
complicated and it's intentional
it is intentional for them to create
such a complicated document for him to
report his income on make it as
complicated as possible and the reason
why is because when someone is looking
at it no average person I mean I've
looked at a lot of tax returns in my
life and they just they're a foreign
language
they're a foreign language there's
certain things you know about them but
you're not really sure it's it's [ __ ]
gobbledygook
and it's intentional on his part it's
gonna take a while to smoke out a lot of
the stuff in its tax returns now I
believe
that there's not going to be a lot of
criminal liability built in his tax
returns again that's the intention
he's paid people a lot of money to make
sure he can cheat on his taxes
and generally speaking they don't put
tax cheats in prison they don't they
don't normally don't even criminally
prosecute them they civilly prosecute
them like what you're seeing in New York
with Tish James the Attorney General how
she is going to civilly prosecute the
Trump organization and basically cut it
off at the kneecaps for the tax fraud
and crime that he's committed
now
there has been crime that has been
convicted on 17 counts of the Trump
organization the problem is
in our system of finances he's got a
buffer for that those are businesses
that's not him personally
so it's going to be really hard that's
why it was really hard for the D.A to
rope him in
so we'll see if any kind of criminal
liability happens on either the state
level which probably not going to happen
just James would have already filed
those charges that's why she's going for
the Civil Trial
but the southern district of New York
could receive referrals
um from the Manhattan DA's office about
the tax returns but folks I'm telling
you if you're counting on the taxes
putting him in prison you're going to be
sitting for a long long long time
a long time you're going to be waiting
for him to go to prison if you're
counting on the tax returns to put in
there
it's the liability of January 6.
and I'm not even going to say the
documents case anymore because they're
one and the same January 6 is the
documents case the documents case is
January 6. as we watch these transcripts
roll out we just have a lot of news
a flood waterfalls of news
that it's hard to keep up with I told
you the other day when these transcripts
and we saw Ray Epps name appear on the
list of transcripts that was gonna be
released I told you that that would [ __ ]
the bed and it has
the rayaps he's not a fed he's not
he wasn't isn't it probably never will
be
I mean are there questions around raps
and his son yes and it talks about it in
the transcripts
but again it's always nonsense from the
right they're always trying to distract
why do you think Hunter Biden's laptop
is is such a s uh a subject in their
circle jerk
it is such a subject in their social
jerk because there's nothing there for
Hunter Biden's Lambda nothing
not a goddamn thing it doesn't exist
that's why it's such a good distraction
just like these tax returns as much as
we want to see
the evidence quote
of maybe some of his financial crimes it
folks the tax returns great the only
thing we need to do is use the tax
returns to mock him
that's how we create a national
narrative in messaging that's why how we
piss him off I read you his statement
he is super concerned that people are
gonna know he's broke
he's not talking about crimes about his
tax returns he's saying hey I'm still
Rich because I own golf courses
don't believe them when they tell you I
have no cash because he doesn't have any
cash he spends cash faster than any
[ __ ] we've ever seen in history
that's why he has to continually grift
his supporters and that's why he's very
upset not only for his ego's sake
but for his Griff's sake to make sure
that his supporters still know hey I'm
worth a lot of money
give me more of it
it doesn't make any sense it's not
supposed to
but that's what is happening so we
cannot use the tax returns as this big
huge thing where he's going to go to
prison for tax evasion blah blah blah no
you have to mock him that he's broke
and you have to mock his supporters that
he's baroque
and this is just the evidence to prove
that he's [ __ ] flat broke
and there he's gonna go on and on and on
and on about this for weeks that oh well
my property value doesn't show up in my
tax returns
and he's gonna claim he's he's probably
going to do a list right he's going to
do a list of his properties and how much
these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] aren't
worth
he's going to claim they're worth all
kinds of [ __ ] money which isn't even
close to their value
Jesus Christ he did it in the statement
when they released his tax returns about
the DC Hotel
using Forbes as his Source again if
you're believing Forbes and what they
say about the richest man or
billionaires or whatever the [ __ ] their
list of people who are rich
whoo whoosh
Forbes is unreliable
heavily unreliable
because even if he has the title or his
businesses have the title or the deed
to these properties they're in Hawk to
the bank
okay somewhere some some some shady ass
Bank overseas somewhere
owns the note
owns the debt
or maybe maybe just maybe he owes Saudis
to give
golf matches at these golf courses now
one more thing I want to get to
in the first 30 here because I I we
talked about this Andrew Tate Greta
Thunder
Saga yesterday a lot and all almost
immediately when we went off air
and a lot of a lot of people were
commenting on the video hey didn't you
know I did not know that he was arrested
and raided for human trafficking while
we were on the air it happened directly
after almost the news broke almost
immediately maybe they were waiting for
me to get done
um
reacting to his video now yesterday when
I did the video when I was playing the
video and we were talking about it I was
really [ __ ] confused if you remember
about why he had the pizza boxes right
I'm talking about Andrew Tate in the
video of his response to Greta thundberg
owning his ass by telling him
her email was small dick energy energy
at getalife.com and he in the video
somewhat seemed to believe it
but at one point in the video and we may
rewatch it today I don't know
um
briefly
um at one point he looks over
and then he asked them to bring him the
pizza boxes right and he has these what
appear to be empty pizza boxes because
they're non-recyclable so he's bringing
them into the video and as part of the I
don't know it doesn't make any sense
really it really doesn't make any sense
why he had the pizza boxes in the video
other than he was trying to own Greta
the libtard because they were
non-recyclable
[Laughter]
oh turns out turns out
um Andrew Tate and his brother are
wanted
fugitives for human sex trafficking him
him his brother and two others were
arrested after they raided their home
and they found six women there now
um
I can't think Greta thundberg enough she
is a great climate activist
um she is one who gives not too many
[ __ ] about how many people get offended
when she talks about the climate I think
we need more like her in the world not
just in this country but in the world
um to push for uh climate helping
climate change and making sure we we
we're not going to reverse it but it's
some some to some extent make sure we
stop climate change and global warming
I mean with the weather that we have
it's [ __ ] crazy I mean I don't know
if you experienced this country in the
last week but it was negative 65 degrees
with a blizzard and then the next day it
was 80 degrees outside like it was
[ __ ] spring or some [ __ ]
so we need to you know be
careful with the planet because look
we're not going to kill the planet the
planet will kill us before we kill the
planet the planet is much more resilient
than our then and then the human race
for crying out loud but here's the thing
Greta thundberg and does a lot of
climate activism but I had no idea I had
no idea
no clue
that she was in the camp of absolutely
destroying right-wing trolls
um she has it's a beautiful thing to
watch frankly
um as she destroys Andrew Tate and all
his supporters with just a few
just a few texts it's it's just a little
bit of text it's just a few tweets and
she is absolutely destroyed destroyed
Andrew Tate
and it's toxic masculinity following
it's [ __ ] beautiful to watch
now
of course uh the right wing and Andrew
what what is top G by the way what the
[ __ ] is this is this something that he
says a lot top G was trending yesterday
and uh at first I thought it meant Greta
top G Greta I mean that's what I thought
but apparently it's something he says a
lot he talks about the Matrix like it's
a docu-series he really is a [ __ ]
bonehead but the point is is he's been a
criminal for a long time and apparently
some of the reporting is from the
Romanian officials that Andrew Tate and
his brother
have been human trafficking since early
of 2021 so almost two years that that's
known
um I guess there was two women that were
actually being looked for they're
missing and there ended up being Six
Women and apparently they were
shooting porno or something right I I
don't I don't know they were had a
website I I'm not really sure what the
what the [ __ ] they're doing
um
but they were they had women in his
compound and they were making sex videos
and posting them on some kind of website
where you paid money I guess I don't I'm
not really sure of the details of that
and it sounds like
some sort of [ __ ]
um weirdo website where you pay Andrew
Tate to watch it I don't know I have no
idea look I'm not I'm not gonna Kink
shame I'm not gonna porn shame you know
you do what you want to do as long as
it's legal
if it's legal and consensual fine
whatever right you know who am I to who
am I to shame you
but here's the thing
these women were held against their will
and coerced against their will to do
these things apparently that's what the
Romanian authorities are alleging that's
why they arrested them
um they're not going to have bail
apparently so
um it looks like Andrew is going to be
off the internet for a while
so it is up to us it is up to us to drag
him now I said yesterday I told Andrew
yesterday and he just didn't [ __ ]
listen
I told him that I did not want to talk
about this story until next week
sometime
and almost immediately almost
immediately after I turned my microphone
off I'd find out that he's been arrested
on human traffic charges in Romania what
in the [ __ ]
the funniest part is the the best part
about the whole thing
is that in the video when he's trying to
own the libs with the stupid [ __ ]
pizza boxes bit he thinks it's funny oh
it's hilarious Andrew great comedy gold
he doxes himself
he basically gives his location because
of this pizza chain
and they discovered they pretty much
figured out that yeah now we know where
he is now I said yesterday
I said yesterday if he owned all these
33 cars which he does not because he
said he does
okay you just take anything they say and
know that it's a [ __ ] line I mean
George Santos is not an outlier here in
the right wing okay he's not they're all
[ __ ] Liars they're all [ __ ]
deceptive it's all projection it's all
[ __ ] George Santos just doesn't know
when this when to cut the
cut it off he's he lies about everything
and he tells two sets of Lies and he
records it and it's weird but it's not
unique in the right wing it's not unique
in in republicanism it's not unique in
Maga it's not
it's actually part of their Foundation
to be complete utter [ __ ] Liars
but Andrew Tate
the the beauty
the beauty
of what
Andrew Tate has done here
I I don't even know if you can wrap up
2022 in a better bow
then absolutely how this is ending up I
mean think about it we get all the
transcripts from the January 6 select
committee we're getting Trump's tax
returns as a New Year's Eve gift
Andrew Tate the biggest right-wing troll
on the internet such a [ __ ] box just a
[ __ ] utter [ __ ] box
gets arrested on human trafficking
charges the right wing the trolls who
are in your comments they're like oh
Democrats Democrats are a bunch of child
chicks traffickers
and they're like I love Andrew Tate top
G you're free Andrew what the [ __ ] ever
listen
every single bit of it all of it all the
way down to the stupid [ __ ] laptop
talk
it's all projection
every single bit of it remember that as
we go into 2023
it is super important to remember
that all of it everything they say is
just is just like Santos talking I'm
telling you he's not an outlier he's he
he is the establishment in the Maga
Republican the America First Nazi party
George Santos is a lieutenant
and he's a good one because he's a damn
he's a damn shameful liar
Shameless doesn't give a [ __ ]
and that's what you need to remember
about 2023 also what you need to
remember is today is Friday
bonehead of the week we are back with
bonehead of the week where you vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez break it
down in the second hour and yes I can
confirm for the audience that Gabe
Sanchez my co-host and executive
producer is here today for bonehead of
the week we have Gabe back today so get
excited in the chat also we have a new
moderator in the chat
Cynthia rice welcome Cynthia
thank you for joining us as a great
moderator give all the moderators love
in the chat
I guess they're asking for the chat to
be slower too I don't know maybe I can
slow it down and we're at uh we're at 10
right now
I'm gonna go to 20. let's try 15. how's
that sound let's try 15. see how that
works
slow mode changed
so everybody Welcome the new moderators
give the moderators love for the new
year as we go into the new year and also
do not forget
because we appreciate your support here
at the Tony Michaels podcast
so do not forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel while you're here you do
not want to miss a single episode
speaking that on Monday for the New
Year's holiday we will not have a show
on Monday so we will be back on Tuesday
just want to remind everyone of that
we'll we're going to take one more day
one more day for the holiday and then
we're gonna go full drive baby
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch make sure
to download every single episode on
Apple Spotify Google make sure to leave
us a great review on your favorite
directory why you're there subscribing
also go follow us on Twitter at the Tony
Michaels POD at the Tony Michaels at I
am Gabe Sanchez and if you're on the
Midas touch Facebook page right now make
sure to head over to our Facebook page
at the Tony Michaels everybody stick
around
we're gonna have plenty of boneheads
today and I got some video
I want you to watch stick around don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
yeah I have some clips I want to show
you
um because these tax returns are rolling
out people are evaluating them again I
told you one of the biggest pieces of
new so far is yes yes yes he did have
foreign bank accounts
um and apparently he had them all the
way up until
um the the tax returns that we have
which is 2020 I believe
um but but here is a clip from CNN and
we're gonna go straight to it and and
let's just listen
the other thing and this is important
because it was one of the things that we
are looking for in these additional
documents is his foreign bank accounts
we have just learned that he did hold
foreign bank accounts the entire time
that he was in office in 2015 actually
let's start with 2016. he had bank
accounts in the United Kingdom Ireland
China and Saint Martin 2017 UK Ireland
and China and then 2018 and 2020 just in
the UK the reason why this is so
important we're going to do a deeper
dive into all these foreign entities is
because the entanglement that Trump had
with foreign business was a huge part of
the narrative while he was in office and
now we're going to find out actually how
far that actually went are there any
foreign owned companies who are his
business associates so again more there
you go he had foreign bank accounts of
course I mean this is not a surprise to
me
it's not a surprise to me that he had
borne bank accounts while he was the
president of the United States I wonder
I wonder if someone could hold that
against him hmm
[Music]
I wonder if there could have been
influence used with those foreign bank
accounts
I mean I guess we're going to find out
you [ __ ] around that's what happens you
find out um I do want to point something
out also someone said speaking of
finding out I mean let me let me retweet
this here so everyone can see that clip
from CNN about his tax returns and let's
see there's a there's one I want to show
you here
oh [ __ ] and this um this idiot uh enters
the Nick or um excuse me the Andrew Tate
story
um you guys know Nick Adams here it is
Nick Adams alpha male alpha male Nick
Adam his [ __ ] idiot
okay if you're not questioning every
single person who has the words alpha
male in their [ __ ] Twitter
description at this point and who semps
for Andrew Tate well you're not doing it
correctly but Nick Adams decides to
Andrew Tate's biggest fan Nick Adams
today decides
decides to chime in on the Trump tax
returns he said Donald Trump's tax
returns are none of your business and I
said they are now [ __ ] they are our
business they were our business
he's running for president now they
continue to be our business [ __ ]
and if you're not aware that that
someone who is and wants to be or was
President of the United States their
personal finances are our [ __ ]
business and the reason why
is the [ __ ] we're gonna find out about
his foreign bank accounts
in these tax returns in the days to come
I'm sure next week we'll know more and
more and more but again is it about
crime not really is it criminal to hold
foreign bank accounts I mean maybe
but what the [ __ ] do you think they
would say
if Joe Biden had Chinese bank accounts
that [ __ ] would be in your [ __ ]
thread every time you post something it
wouldn't even matter if it was about if
it was about politics
if you got politics in your bio and you
post a video about your cat they would
be in your thread talking about how Joe
Biden has Chinese bank accounts hell
they already are
and Joe Biden has released his tax
returns just like every [ __ ]
before him besides the Cheeto dust cue
in honor
he's a [ __ ] Criminal
and the thing is he doesn't want you
know that he's broke he's a fraud Nick
you [ __ ] idiot
this guy this guy is the biggest fluffer
I've ever seen in my life Nick Adams
that is
but yes Nick they are our [ __ ]
business dummy
they are our business he was our
president
you dumb son of a [ __ ] this is the
problem that the right wing has they
want they want Joe Biden's tax return
anyone know that you've got him by the
way they want 100 by this laptop
that doesn't exist
but they don't want to see the truth
about their [ __ ] orange Mussolini
Jesus good [ __ ] night okay so um
let's go to do
let's see if we can find uh there we go
let's see if we can find some more
um footage all right here here is uh let
me go to this David Corn posted this he
is
um heavily looking at these tax returns
as we go and of course this was
um this morning I I said China China but
David Corn says a bank account in China
uh Trump tax returns here is the here's
the the screenshot of the form
it says schedule B form 1040A or 10 40.
and now this is 2016. you can see here
when this tax return uh form was last
edited so I don't know what this is from
2016. oh yeah it does say during 2016
you can see right here 2016 United
Kingdom Ireland and China Saint Martin
jaina chain it chain it chain it chaina
the Cheeto dust q and honor loves his
Chinese bank account
loves it
this is 2016. what's did he what year
did that [ __ ] technically get
elected what year was it hmm I wonder
listen don't ever let these
[ __ ] tell you about bidens and
China and Corruption don't ever let them
get away with it
you got all the ammo you need now
all of it you got the truth okay let's
see do we have do I'm just trying to
look for some other stuff he's tax
returns is just being released within
the last uh hour or so
um
and we're gonna get to bonehead of the
week here in just a few in about 20
minutes or so but I want to see if I can
find any new
oh God damn oh God damn
[Music]
sorry Andrew Tate is showing up
everywhere on the internet
um
it's it's so funny When Worlds Collide
um I got a teenage son and he he's on
the internet right
he knows the internet of course you know
he's a young kid
and um
normally our worlds don't Collide I talk
about politics he's not really
interested but last night he came in the
kitchen he said did you hear about
Andrew Tate
and I said did you see the video
so we had this moment where the two
generations climbed and that's what
Andrew Tate has done for all of us is
bring us all together in one form and
one one big meeting
to know that the right wing is the one
who are traffickers
you [ __ ] boneheads you are the one
who are sexual deviants you were the
ones running around
obsessed with other people's [ __ ]
genitalia and what gender they are you
want to see it you want to inspect it at
kids sporting events
you're you're terrified you're terrified
for for people to know that there's
lgbtq community members in your
community terrified of it
you're absolutely you're absolutely gut
checked gut checked by the fact that you
would look at a picture of a beautiful
woman and discover that she's
transgender
it really is something else it really is
something else this Andrew Tate stuff
because they're so there's so many
layers to this onion
so much so that again it's leaking past
generational norms
and it's exposing the right
the right wing as the ones who are the
sexual deviants you are the human
traffickers Jesus Christ you remember
pizzagate
Hillary Clinton was supposed to have I
don't know children in a basement of a
pizza parlor in DC the pizza parlor
didn't even have a basement a guy went
to shoot the place up with a gun
they drove them so mad with these
delusional deflections and projections
of Lies
and here we are here we are right now
December 30th we're about to end the
year 2022 and we finally we finally find
out that pizza gate is from the right
you got to see this this is this is
[ __ ] real I I saw this tweet
last night in a screenshot
and I just had to go confirm it
because the whole big dick energy at
getalife.com
Greta that was beautiful I mean
absolutely beautiful
but this tweet if there was an award
for the greatest tweet ever look at it's
got
2.1 million likes 65 million views
Elon only wishes
he could get this kind of reaction on
one of his stupid [ __ ] poles
and here's Greta
with the simple but eloquent tweet of
the year
this is what happens when you don't
recycle your pizza boxes
you can't make this [ __ ] up
this is real life this is re you are
living in such a crazy [ __ ] time it
is such a time to be alive where a
climate activist a teenage climate actor
she's 19 years old
smart
as a [ __ ] tack one of the smartest
that you will that you will see
about climate and climate activism
she has an account on the internet
this human trafficker and scumbag vile
[ __ ] scumbag in human trafficker
sends her a message on the same
Internet site
she responds with a quippy fakie maldris
he creates a video
post it on that internet site
and because of the pizza boxes because
he was trying to make a joke which was
not funny by the way
he gets caught for human sex trafficking
and then she replies with this tweet
this is what happens when you don't
recycle your pizza boxes
folks
everyone thinks the internet is a bad
thing
everyone thinks the internet is going to
destroy us
we just don't fully understand it yet
that's the problem we haven't fully
wrapped our heads around
how powerful of a tool this really is
but Greta gets it she really does get it
and she destroyed
one of their kings their top G
in a matter of two posts
two she posted two
tweets on the internet and destroyed
Andrew Tate
and really honestly if you look at it
he destroyed himself
he destroyed himself and the reason why
it's because it is all projection with
these [ __ ] idiots
every single time
every single time
it never fails and it won't you can
count on it
thank you Greta for um ramping 2022 up
in a nice little bow for us that's the
greatest tweet I don't know I think I'm
[ __ ] printed out and framed that some
[ __ ] and hang it on the wall maybe back
here or something
whoo it does deserve an award I believe
[Laughter]
man Max says because he's an arrogant
prick well I mean his arrogance did get
him in trouble here
but that's the reason that's but see
what you have to understand about their
arrogance is they think that's their
secret weapon they think their
confidence and their arrogance is their
secret weapon
that that they're in in they cannot be
punished there is no accountability
because those strong and so manly
the [ __ ] out of here
that's what it really is
what else do we have in the chat
we got anything else going on in the
chat what do you guys think about the um
the tax returns so far I'm telling you
you're gonna see this stupid [ __ ] okay
so I I want to give you a lesson in
messaging while we're talking about this
uh yesterday I kind of gave you a lesson
in messaging about the Al Franken thing
I remember
um George Santos and the story goes on
and on and on he's under federal
investigation now and probably State
investigation there's going to be a lot
of criminal investigations in the in the
George Santos not about his lies it's
not a crime to lie in front of a camera
a lie into a microphone it is however
um criminal to take money from certain
entities and not pay taxes and pay
certain things and bribes them yeah so
that is Criminal
um and that is probably where uh this
criminal investigation is going to lead
us to the money uh with George Santos I
mean as far as his lies that's just you
know he's a republican what are you
gonna do
he's a [ __ ] liar
but yesterday when I was talking about
that everyone on the internet was
comparing him and Al Franken and again
stop doing that [ __ ] stop it you're not
helping the national narrative into
National messaging the same way the same
way with these tax returns and yes uh
here's someone on YouTube you got it
right mock the tax returns don't call
for him to be arrested if you're stoking
up that he needs to be arrested for
these tax returns that's going to be the
wrong message
that's going to be the absolute wrong
message the message you need to have is
that he's a broke [ __ ] he's a
fraud he's a phony he's never been a
billionaire never will be a billionaire
he's broke ain't got no money that's why
he's grifting you dummy that's the
narrative that's the narrative you want
to give them an off ramp
here's the off ramp for you that the
reason why he keeps grifting you the
reason why he keeps asking for your cash
is because he doesn't have any listen it
doesn't matter how many properties you
own
yeah
it doesn't matter how many properties
you own
it only matters
it only matters that the bank owns them
and because they own them you have no
cash
um Robin's trying to tell me something
there's alerts and I know murders
already reigned oh yes yes there were
some murders in Idaho and they caught
them in Pennsylvania this morning I
haven't looked at too many details on
that is that is that what you're trying
to give me an alarm about you know
I don't know
um
we got breaking news or something
do we have breaking news
[Music]
I don't I don't see it uh send me that
send me that link in the uh
somewhere else
um uh yes there is breaking news send me
that link somewhere else I can't pull it
out of the chat here
um so there apparently is breaking news
I I I I I is it with the Idaho murders
because I did see this they did arrest
someone in Pennsylvania they caught they
caught someone in Pennsylvania for the
four uh murders in Idaho I believe it's
um in Moscow Idaho I believe where the
murders took place
um here I've got the uh here I got a
clip of it right here and here here is
uh here's the story irrigation CNN's
Veronica Miracle is in Idaho uh she is
on the phone with the latest Veronica
what can you tell us
amra we just heard moments ago and
confirmed CNN can confirm according to
two federal law enforcement sources that
a suspect has been taken into custody in
connection to this investigation into
the murders of four University of Idaho
students the sources they're telling CNN
the arrest was made by the FBI in
northeastern Pennsylvania all the way on
the other side of the country this is
her artification CNN okay so there's the
story
um again I I wasn't aware of these uh
this quadruple homicide but apparently
uh there's been a murder of four
students in an Idaho uh Moscow Idaho
apparently and then they caught this
person in Pennsylvania so I think that's
the breaking news everyone was was
looking for and so they've caught the
person who murdered those four students
in Moscow Idaho
[Music]
do they have they released
the name
yes it looks like
looks like he is a
um he is a
graduate student so he was a student at
the same University possibly I don't
know I don't want to get too much in the
weeds I haven't read too much about this
story so I don't want to get this wrong
um but apparently he is also a student
he's a graduate student
um and he killed these other four
students
in Idaho and um
[Laughter]
apparently he was a criminology uh
student oh Jesus Christ well you know
why why why why wouldn't he be
why wouldn't he be a student of crime I
don't know
yes [ __ ] this country I tell you what
now what a time we live in what a time
we live in
um
yeah so they're releasing his name I'm
not going to say it on there [ __ ] this
guy you know you yeah you don't need to
become famous here on my show over him
killing four [ __ ] students he can go
[ __ ] himself
um as far as I'm concerned and then it
did let's see what else do we have
Chinese or other news why is Ted Bundy
is this is is Ted bunny trending because
of this gang oh [ __ ] see there's the
reason why there's a reason why I'm not
gonna say his [ __ ] name
again it goes back to this messaging
[ __ ] ah the media is so horrible at this
the media is so horrible at this again
the other day Santos everyone's talking
about it he needs to resign he needs to
resign and frankly again I don't want
him to resign he needs to take his seat
I hope he I hope he serves every single
day as a republican fraud in Congress
every [ __ ] day of it
they earned it
they earned it and you know everyone's
like oh the constituents are pissed off
now listen these you go vote for a
republican you know you're voting for a
[ __ ] fraud
stop acting like this Santos guy is
different than any other Republican and
then for the media and any of you out
there in the audience or anyone on
social media to compare him to Al
Franken you people are just not doing it
correctly
compare him to the other Republicans
Jesus Christ
I mean for [ __ ] sake there's so many
to choose from Rand Paul liar fraud
Donald Trump liar fraud Margaret Taylor
green liar fraud
Marco Rubio liar fraud Madison cawthorne
liar fraud why me the list goes on Jim
Jordan liar fraud Lauren bobert lying
for I mean if you got an R next to your
name you're a [ __ ] phony
why are you comparing George Santos to
anyone but Republicans
two they are just like this guy don't
compare him to Ted Bundy what are you
doing why are you trying to make the guy
famous stop trying to make him famous
let the justice system put him away
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] him
and the horse he rode in on
okay same way with Andrew Tate
you wanna you should start comparing him
to all the other [ __ ] sex traffickers
in the Republican party and the Maga
movement Matt gatz Donald Trump
the list goes on and on I mean there's
an extensive list out there of predators
that are Republicans and again it's the
same thing
just goes on and on that's the narrative
you got to get the messaging correct
that's what we have to have
um oh Jesus Christ
Kirk Cameron is trending too this can't
is this is this more Andrew Tate's [ __ ]
it can't it surely it's not right oh my
God
we're going to talk about more of the
Andrew Tate stuff uh here in bonehead
because Gabe Sanchez
he actually
um
went to a Twitter space last night that
had kim.com and a few others and they
were simping and for Andrew Tate
basically on the free Andrew
uh train Jesus Christ
you can't get any lower than look
they're calling for all the Democrats to
be prosecuted and [ __ ] for child sex
trafficking they want to shut down they
want to shut down people reading books
to children because they're drag queens
because they're reading books to
children oh Jesus
and
and they're in their simping for someone
who was just arrested on human sex
trafficking charges
him and three others were caught with
six women that were held against their
will
okay
you're you're after the wrong
[ __ ] you're answered the wrong
[ __ ] yes and someone pointed
out who always came and last night
kim.com did block Gabe
kim.com and I I'm I'm not really to
um I don't know who this kim.com
character is to be quite honest
um I'm not really 100 sure
um I I don't know I just don't know
about kim.com but today Gabe Sanchez is
going to give us a rundown of who this
is now this guy's running from the law
too he's trying to they're the US is
trying to extradite him to the United
States for crimes that he committed here
I'm from the Netherlands I think or New
Zealand maybe it's New Zealand is it New
Zealand I don't know he's going to give
us the rundown of who kim.com is and why
he's simping for Andrew Tate but it's so
important I know it doesn't feel like
the Andrew Tate thing has anything to do
with politics but it has everything to
do with it
Andrew Tate has been on the Maga Trump
train from the beginning the entirety of
the whole [ __ ] personality
of anyone in Maga in in the America
First Nazi party
its foundation
is the same [ __ ]
that Andrew Tate has been selling for a
long time
a long time same stuff same [ __ ]
[ __ ] how do you think they attract
all these [ __ ] disgruntled trumped up
white males
I think it was uh someone from tyt you
know I'm not usually a tyt fan but she
said yesterday that there should be
someone who can attract these toxic
males that the left doesn't do it
correctly hey look over here
where you been I do it every day
ridiculous
but we have to fight back and we have to
fight back with messaging and
information that's how they're doing it
how do you think there's so many people
so [ __ ] deluded
that they think Democrats are child sex
traffickers
while they're supporting the sex
traffickers
at the same time and and they Breeze
over it like ah well Andrew Tate can't
be a human trafficker there's no way
he talks about how terrible it is when
Democrats do it yeah he's saying that
to distract you dummy
just can't get over it now let's see
here sorry my uh my mouse was I think I
don't know what the hell's going on here
okay and then
there's a link here what's what's this
link someone sent me a link
is there something important going on
now big news
[Music]
um
Richie Torres is entering and reducing a
bill requiring candidates to disclose
under oath their employment education
military history how is this the oh
Jesus
the stop Santos act okay again again
this this is kind of a good thing let me
let me pull this up here
I'm gonna show you this Cappy
paste
but here's the thing if he did this we
wouldn't we would only have one
political priority
okay
I'm just saying this if this is if this
is real if if they do no that's not what
I want what the [ __ ] is going on
sorry I'm having trouble over here it's
Friday what are you gonna do it's Friday
bone end of the week coming up at you
here really soon I promise I promise
Gabe Sanchez is going to be back with us
back why is it doing that
okay let's try this again
um it's just not it's not cooperating
this morning
there's there we go ah there we go okay
here's the here's the tweet and they're
sending me boom
big news I'm introducing a build
to require candidates to disclose
underwrote their employment education
military history so we can punish
candidates who lie to their voters about
their qualifications
it will be called to stop another
non-truthful office Seeker the Santos
Act
okay the problem here is is that there
this is not gonna fly
because how the [ __ ] would any
Republican ever get elected I mean yeah
it's a good idea Regina is saying it's a
good idea everyone's like yeah 100 this
is great
how the [ __ ] would they ever get in a
republican elected anywhere ever
and that sounds great right that sounds
great but look our system is not set up
for one party rule it really isn't
that's not how our system of
government's set up and that's the
problem that we're having right now we
really do have a fundamental problem in
our government
in the way that we govern because we
have a party
that is not interested in democracy
they're not interested in advancing our
democracy they're not they want to kill
it that's the problem that we have right
now is we do not have two political
parties interested in democracy
only one of them that's the challenge
right that's why it feels like we're
divided we're not divided it's just the
majority of people want democracy
there's a slim view that don't but they
hold a shitload of power because they've
gerrymandered their way into it
they represent the minority opinion on
almost every single policy point
and not only do they represent the
minority ideology of almost every single
policy point in this country they want
to destroy our system of democracy they
want to destroy it they want
authoritarianism right and that's and it
sounds great to never have a republican
ever elected ever in the history of ever
ever
but our system really fundamentally is a
two-party system and until we get to a
place where they're not on every single
policy point the minority
of ideology right I mean just go down
the list women's rights education
Health Care
uh I mean a foreign policy energy you go
down every single [ __ ] point and they
represent the minority ideology on every
single one of them that's bad for a
two-party system of government that's
horrible and for anyone out there that
says then we need to tear it down and
rebuild it you're you're just like them
you're just like them the two-party
system does work when the parties are
interested in democracy
they Carrie lake is still yelling at
that stupid [ __ ] is still yelling and
screaming about how she won when she
lost
she may she may end up committing crimes
to go so far as to lie about how she
[ __ ] about how she [ __ ] lost
there's gonna be a lot of people
that that lose their law license just to
defend her it's ridiculous
but this is where we're at they are not
interested
in democracy they are not interested in
advancing the quality and Equity they
don't want it
and that is the real division we have
we're not divided 50 50. you [ __ ]
kidding me the [ __ ] out of here
that's all nonsense hell Jesus half the
[ __ ] people who voted for Trump would
agree with Democrats on policy points
if you just gave them the bare bones
policy
so I I appreciate this this um
this sentiment
where you'd have to disclose your
employment education and military
history
but listen it's not going to happen in
Congress folks
when our founding fathers framed our
government
they gave the power to the people
originally and it was through the House
of Representatives you got to remember
the president didn't have much power the
executive branch didn't have that much
power
when we were first framed
this the Senate was all appointed
it was only the House of Representatives
of where you get your representation of
your government and your voice
they handle Appropriations they pass
legislation and policy
the power was with the Congress was with
the House of Representatives that's
where the people's power was
and now today
the people don't even pay attention they
say term limits turn the match turn we
need term why do you already have term
limits
you already have them George Santos does
not need to resign the people in New
York's third need to vote him out in
2024.
that's the answer it's every two years
that's why they set it up every two
years to vote for your representative in
Congress
they have term limits
we just don't [ __ ] pay attention
and we don't message correctly
we don't play politics and we need to oh
yes everyone's bringing up that this is
the 300th episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast and that is correct it is the
300th episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast what's crazy about it
I did not plan this right I didn't plan
this but this would be the last episode
of the year
but it is it is and here we are and
we're gonna do bone end of the week
let's see let's see if um Mr Sanchez
see if he's uh
be if he's ready
T if he is ready uh let's see let's go
see if we get the assets and all
right yeah Gabe Sanchez has been under
the weather I'll let him explain but
he's got a great story to tell you
um about
that uh Twitter spaces last night about
Andrew Tate and he's going to tell you
this story
um in bonehead of the week because
Andrew Tate was on the Bonet who won I
don't even know who won I didn't check
out the poll this morning yet uh I I
like to be surprised sometimes
everyone's giving love to Gabe
free game
oh Margie says free Gabe
um this weekend is New Year's Eve
it is New Year's Eve this weekend and I
want you to
all be super safe have a good
celebration be happy that 2022 is
finally over in 2023 is here
and be happy of the the great bow that
was tied into 22 at the very end it
really is turning out to be a great year
and I know 2023 will be better than
2022. we'll ever dream of and the reason
why is because you're here
the best audience in the world
here at the Tony Michaels podcast so be
safe have a happy New Year and this
weekend make sure when you're
celebrating
I mean okay overdo it just yeah go ahead
you deserve it
it's been a long goddamn year okay it
was a long year we fought hard we fought
hard we deserve to go into 23 2023 and
with some Styles so have fun but be safe
um stick around we're gonna be right
back don't go anywhere don't go anywhere
uh we'll be back I'm gonna try to get
Gabe Sanchez on the line here so we can
start bone end of the week here really
soon we'll be right back right after
these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
Andrew Andrew I told you
I said yesterday [ __ ] do not
make any news until after the New Year
yeah but here we are here we are got the
news Andrew Dayton been arrested on
human trafficking charges and alls we're
waiting on now
all I'm waiting on is to see who's going
to send for this [ __ ] right I'm
just waiting um you'll see uh we brought
up Nick Adams earlier and I want to show
you
um because they're trying to figure out
oh these these [ __ ] idiots are really
trying to figure out hard
um rather they're going to send for him
or not here is it
[Music]
um
oh my God this guy oh my God he tweets
so and let me show you let me just show
you Jesus Christ you're sweating I tweet
so much here's the one tweet I responded
to this morning Donald Trump's tax
returns are near your business yeah they
are they are now [ __ ]
um
okay if you're not aware if you're not
aware of this guy's a fan if this guy's
a fan of Andrew Tate he tweeted two
hours ago president Donald Trump is
coming back rather the woke shrill
feminist like it or not oh my God you
are so [ __ ] butt hurt that women
don't like you Nick it is pathetic get
over it accept it embrace it move on
yeah exactly get over it dude the [ __ ]
over it accept it that Donald Trump is a
[ __ ] criminal and a piece of [ __ ] and
no one likes him embrace it Nick just
Embrace that he's a pile of garbage
embrace it and then move on you dumb
[ __ ] Okay
um did it do oh here's a video of this
[ __ ] idiot
um
oh my God more of the Hooters stuff
more of the Hooters [ __ ] the feminist
left hates Hooters because they can't
cancel it what are you talking about
look I I if you want to go work and wear
that kind of outfit and serve Wings to
people fine whatever I don't care
as long as they're not as long as
Hooters isn't doing [ __ ] they shouldn't
be doing but their employee get the [ __ ]
out of here with this [ __ ]
that the left wants to shut down hooters
this stuff is stupid okay let's um I
wanna I wanna bring up the Andrew Tate
God damn this guy tweets a lot of stupid
[ __ ]
God damn I mean there's gotta be
J here here we go here it is
here is him trying to figure out where
he's gonna stand on Andrew Tate right
now because of Elon we have
um this new
analytics down below your Tweet and it
shows how many Impressions it says views
but it's Impressions right an impression
doesn't necessarily mean of you it just
means it shows up on your feed and
really if you were scrolling down your
feed and you've seen Nick Adams alpha
male you probably wouldn't even read
that [ __ ] right you just keep
going
you should at least and that
[ __ ] has been showing up a lot
in my feed
have you noticed that in your Twitter
like your timeline your your lobby feed
or you're just you know just browsing
a lot of these [ __ ]
right wing
trolls are showing up in your feed it's
really hmm it almost it's almost like
they're doing it intentionally
um but here's what he says here's what
Andrew or excuse me Nick Adams I'm
getting Andrew Tate and Nick Adams
confused it is confusing sometimes
Nick Adams asked the question he crowd
he crowd sources this question to make
sure where he's going to stand on this
he said Do you believe the accusations
made against top G Andrew Tate there's
that top G [ __ ] again
I'm gonna see if Gabe Sanchez knows what
the [ __ ] that means
I haven't really watched a lot of Andrew
take content to be quite honest with you
it doesn't take more than I don't know
five or ten minutes to realize this
guy's a piece of garbage so you don't
really need to watch
a lot of Andrew take content to
understand who he is
he he oh is he's openly openly telling
people that he's a vile piece of [ __ ]
but Nick Adams here
can't figure out for himself now my
guess is top G probably means like top
gangster or some [ __ ] I don't know and
I'm just making a guess right that's
just my guess of what but it's not
something that's bad they think it's
something that's good top G that is
calling Andrew Tate top G
um but he's he's wanting to know
how his audience feels about the
accusations of Andrew Tate before he
weighs in on them right they did this a
lot yesterday they were trying to figure
it out if they can convince the right
wing that hey you know that stuff we've
been saying how bad it is about human
trafficking well it's not really that
bad when someone you like does it
okay they're trying to really try hard
to convince people of this and that's
what this is an attempt to do
is to Gaslight you because number one
he's asking the question rather he
whether you believe the allegation
but then he goes on to call him top G
Andrew Tate so what he's trying to do is
say oh I may believe the allegations but
I don't believe the allegations wink
[ __ ] idiot
ridiculous
but that's where we're at with these
right-wing trolls and again you're if
you're wondering why the Andrew Tate
stuff matters in politics that's exactly
why
zagger white this is gonna they're going
to form a narrative and messaging around
Andrew Tate
the American right the American right
wing the alt-right will try to form
messaging he's oh it's all it's all it's
all trumped up charges they're just
trying to get him it's the Matrix I'm
not kidding you
look look at the [ __ ] head [ __ ] here
let me show you let me show you what I
mean
here is um
here's the brokest man in the world's
account here
uh the brokest man in the world Elon
Musk we're going to talk about this [ __ ]
in bonehead of the week too I think but
look at this [ __ ]
this is what he post this is this is
what Elon posted
just the meme four hours ago
now Elon Musk definitely knows
that Andrew Tate spreads this kind of
conspiracy theory around the Internet
it's one of Andrew Tate's personality
traits that he thinks the Matrix the
movies are a docu-series
it's a documentary right
[ __ ] idiot
and he spreads his [ __ ] around the
internet and his his dumb [ __ ]
right-wing supporters eat it like their
baloney sandwiches
and Elon knows
on his website
Greta thundberg absolutely destroyed
Andrew Tate and Andrew Tate posted a
video on elon's website
that led Romanian authorities to arrest
him to know where his location was
Elon knows this stuff there's no way he
does not know that this happened
he proceeds today
to post a meme that is the same
conspiracy theory
that Andrew Tate likely will use as his
defense for his human trafficking
that it's the Matrix so it's some kind
of conspiracy against me and blah blah
blah they're trying to set me up
it's all to shut me up and cancel me
listen hey Elon you're posting this it
makes me believe you're a human
trafficker dummy
it's only you know the Nick Adams
question about rather you believe the
allegations Elon Musk clearly does not
think what Andrew Tate was doing was
human trafficking
oh he believes the allegations he just
believes what Andrew Tate was doing is
not human trafficking
clearly Andrew Tate is trying to be
canceled I mean Elon gave him back his
[ __ ] a Twitter account
but here's the meme here's what it says
it's of course a a drawing of Keanu
Reeves in The Matrix I I have to
disclose something
and I know this might piss some of you
off and I really don't care I've never
watched The Matrix not [ __ ] one of
them not one of them I haven't watched
them [ __ ] it I don't I don't I don't I
just I'm not gonna watch it
I never get it I didn't I maybe watched
the verse 10 or 15 minutes I've seen the
stupid bullet scene
um you know back then that was great uh
Photography they did a great job with
that film with some of the effects but I
did not watch the film never won't not
going to no
especially especially now that Andrew
Tate thinks it's some kind of docky
series I'm not going to do it but this
is a meme obviously of Keanu Reeves from
The Matrix and it says what if I told
you
the only way to escape the matrix is to
unlearn everything you have been taught
and rebuild your entire belief system
based on critical thought and Analysis
what they're trying to do is mind [ __ ]
you this is what they're talking about
they're trying to mind [ __ ] you you do
to to know truth you do not have to
unlearn everything you know this is
really [ __ ] stupid that that humans
have to unlearn everything they know to
distinguish truth from lies
I don't have to unknown the lies that I
that I were told that I thought was the
truth to know the truth now this is
really stupid [ __ ]
and it ain't no wonder these simps
follow these idiots like pied pipers
what a bunch of [ __ ] boneheads this
is the dumbest thing and I don't know if
this is it's just a quote from the movie
can anyone tell me maybe it is I'm sure
Gabe Sanchez will tell me
um someone says unlearning is a real
thing listen
I I'm you're here every day
um Cebu you're here every day you
comment you engage listen you do not
have to unlearn
to know truth and lies it's not you can
you can know that you believed a lie
that's the truth of it the truth is I
used to I used to believe this stuff I
look listen
I'm gonna tell you a personal story I
grew up in the Catholic Church you guys
knew I grew up in the Catholic church
and when I was being confirmed as a
teenager in the Catholic Church normally
it's in high school is when you're
confirmed
you go through a confirmation class they
do this whole thing
during my confirmation class the topic
of abortion came up of course
because it does in the Catholic church
it's one of their [ __ ] personality
traits
it's how they try to obtain power in
this country
is to deny women their [ __ ] rights to
their bodily autonomy
that's one way to gain patents a really
good way to gain power is to deny
someone else their [ __ ] rights I
don't know if you noticed that
but I was told I was told that I had to
be pro-life to be Catholic I was told in
the confirmation I said why I'm not I'm
not pro-life
I believe a woman has a choice
I was a teenager I said I believe a
woman has a [ __ ] Choice that's their
[ __ ] body that's their [ __ ] choice
round and round we went in the
confirmation class for weeks and weeks
and weeks on end about this issue
and I absolutely would not would not go
against what I knew to be what I thought
I knew what they were saying were
[ __ ] lies I knew what people around
me were believing were [ __ ] lies I
knew the truth
I didn't need to unlearn and they tried
it on me oh baby they tried to unlearn
me all sorts of ways
that me me believing that a woman has a
right to her [ __ ] body just like I
have the right to mine
me believing that somehow is a [ __ ]
lie
and that I needed to be taught and
unlearned
that that was the case
listen
I understand the concept of unlearning
something but you do not have to not
know [ __ ] that you used to know
to know the truth now
you absolutely and that's that's the
problem that we're gonna have with this
off ramp
with Maga and fascism in this country is
because we believe if we if we believe
that they have to unlearn the [ __ ] that
they were being that the [ __ ] that they
were spreading around the [ __ ] that they
were believing
they have to absolutely unlearn that
we're in big trouble
we're in big trouble they could learn
the truth and know what they were saying
and know what they believed were [ __ ]
lies
yes
yes
well and someone points something out
unlearning is the first step in
brainwashing exactly
exactly just what I'm telling you about
my experience when I was being confirmed
into the Catholic Church
this is why I'm no longer I I I left I
literally at one point one day during
this two month long conversation about
how I had to be pro-life to be Catholic
and I absolutely refused
I refused
my classmates would come to me and say
hey you just have to say it you just
have to say that you're pro-life you
don't actually have to be it
and I said well what the [ __ ] does that
what what kind of Courage is that
you can't even you can't even stand up
for what you believe
hmm
I didn't
but again
as Olga points out I'm learning first
step in brainwashing that's why they
want you to unlearn again
I'm learning is forgetting what you know
and as you may know the truth but you
need to know the lines and maybe that's
what Cebu is saying
and if I if it was I apologize
and you can know the truth and know you
were being lied to
that's why that's why these that's why
these [ __ ] these [ __ ] boxes
these right-wing [ __ ] boxes are so
easily diluted
they're so easily diluted
because they think their belief is truth
and it's not that's not how it works
you do not have an opinion that is all
[ __ ] this uh well I got my opinion
and you can't you can't say anything
about my it's my freedom to have an
opinion yes it is your freedom to have
beliefs
you can believe any kind of lie you want
to
but it does not have to live in our
political discourse it does not have to
give life to our society you [ __ ]
idiots
an opinion is based on facts
not delusion
not fraud not unlearning anything
if you have a belief
that is it is it is absolute the
foundation of Lies it is not an opinion
I hate to tell you that
but if you can't form
an opinion around facts it is only a
belief it is only something that is that
is imaginary in your [ __ ] mind
now some of your beliefs may be opinions
it is possible us here you know in the
real world that is Tethered to reality
we normally form our beliefs
and our opinions off of facts
now we don't always get it right I mean
never no human is perfect folks I mean
are you perfect I'm not [ __ ] I'm
definitely not [ __ ] [ __ ] yesterday I
showed up and hung over to the show
everybody knew it too I think I think by
the end of the show it was like God damn
you need some water and coffee we're not
perfect no one is perfect human beings
are not perfect
it's one of the things that makes us
uniquely human okay
and we shouldn't expect Perfection from
anyone
now well Steve says he's almost perfect
almost not quite Steve
but no one is perfect and really
honestly do you want to be would you
want how [ __ ] boring would it be if
so if everyone was perfect
it would be pretty [ __ ] boring
but that does not mean that does not
mean
that you can't you can't be Tethered to
reality
and that's the trouble that we have
is there's a small percentage of people
in this country
that are absolutely
untethered from any sort of reality and
they believe that their beliefs of Lies
is an opinion it's not
it's not you having the opinion that JFK
Jr is still alive that's not an opinion
that's your stupid mind confusing your
deluded little
self
and when we give them oxygen that they
get to have their opinion no you get to
have your beliefs
you can believe anything you want to you
can believe that this [ __ ] is true Elon
you can believe that this is going to
solve all your problems meaning you want
people to think the way you think
people are not always going to think the
way you think Jesus Christ you think
we're going to get rid of fascism hell
no we're not going to get rid of it you
can't kill an idea
you can't kill an idea
I mean it you can get it to go crawl
back underneath this [ __ ] rock but
you're not gonna kill it
our hope is
our hope is though that we can strive
we can strive to be better we can strive
to do better
we can try to be I don't know the best
humans we are possibly can be
which is probably not perfect at all
to be quite honest
I'm feeling better though The Hangover
was is gone and promise promise and next
week
I will probably Tuesday when we come
back from New York New Year's I might
still be hungover then I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna sit here and
Gaslight you and tell you that I don't
like to drink alcohol frankly one of my
most favorite alcohols there is is
Jagermeister people think I'm crazy
I love Jaeger who doesn't like Jager and
if you don't like anger hey that's just
your opinion
that's just your opinion okay my opinion
that Jaeger is good is based in fact and
the fact is
that Jaeger Jaeger is the best the best
alcohol uh MJC she's she's telling truth
in the um
in the chat NJ are great moderator I
love edibles
you sure do MJ
there's nothing wrong with it we're not
perfect why why should we be expected to
be perfect but we should strive to be
better we should strive for equality and
equity
and when you go to the New Years into
the New Year's that is
maybe you have a resolution to you know
lose some weight I I would love to lose
some weight in the 2023.
maybe you have maybe maybe you want to
make more money maybe you want your bank
account to be bigger maybe you want to
have better relationships maybe you want
to finally mend the fences with all your
Maga relatives I don't know [ __ ] I don't
know maybe you do maybe you don't beats
me I don't know what your New Year's
resolution is but as you go into the new
year of 2023 make sure
make sure your uh your resolutions are
at least
based in some fact I don't know do we
have Gabe Sanchez here Gabe Sanchez
paging Gabe Sanchez
see if we we got Gabe going on here
he's gonna make it I promise I'm not
just bullshitting you
he's gonna be here I know it feels like
it we usually we've been going along for
the bonehead of the week now for several
weeks it usually is two and a half hours
shows because of bonehead because it's
just so much boneheadry to get to and
Gabe hasn't been feeling well this week
so he's trying to he's trying to get uh
bonehead done here
um as we wait for the for the assets to
come in all the all the nice little
Graphics that we have for bonehead
um Gabe Sanchez makes all those and
that's another thing that I want you to
do when Gabe Sanchez finally gets here
give him a a great welcome back
um from his vacation
and from his uh what would be sick leave
I guess
we don't get paid much here
oh it's up to you it's only we run on
your support we truly do we run on your
support So if you if you'd like to
support us the best way to support and
for you to get something is go to store
that beat Tony michaels.com go to
store.thetonymichaels.com you can buy up
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not Liberty also grab Ron DeSantis can
go [ __ ] himself merch
it's over there as well coffee mugs yeah
t-shirt hoodie
you know if it's cold outside we still
have the dark Brandon merch
everyone loved the dark branded we have
dank Brandon uh for
the edible the edible Community like MJ
dank Brandon is still over there on the
store not the Tony michaels.com you can
also go to the Tony michaels.com
thetonymichaels.com
and give us financial support there as
well the links are all there and really
you should you should follow us in 2023
if you're not following us on Facebook
go follow us on 2020 in 2023 at the Tony
Michaels you download twitch a lot of
people like the twitch chat you can go
uh it's free I don't get anything for
twitch I know some people say I get paid
for twitch but I haven't figured it out
yet I have no idea it's about
commercials in your prime your Amazon
Prime account or some [ __ ] I don't know
also download every single episode in
2023 don't miss a single one make sure
to go subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast on your favorite directory also
follow us on Twitter at the Tony
Michaels podcast and again don't forget
to hit the Subscribe button if you're
here on YouTube we're still waiting on
Gabe Sanchez
Sanchez paging paging Gabe Sanchez
paging paging Gabe Sanchez
um we'll see if he uh I I swear to you
I'm not just bullshitting here
I'm not just bullshitting you he's here
I think maybe
um Maybe
oh yes this is going to be a two and a
half hour show folks we're gonna go a
little long
um oh someone was saying uh under doggy
here from twitch saying I love Gabe's
last what was that everyone go watch
Gabe Sanchez what was that
um on on Midas Touch YouTube channel you
go to Midas Touch YouTube's Channel you
can see his what was that there
he does these great great little pieces
I'm sure I'm sure that Andrew Tate's
gonna work in I'm sure there'll be one
on the Trump tax returns there's
probably going to be one on the
transcripts
as soon as he's feeling better and he
gets me he gets me these bonehead assets
let's see man where in the hell
nope that's not it that's not it
Gabe Sanchez paging Sanchez
what are you guys doing for the New
Year's are you gonna throw a big party
are you staying at home are you gonna
watch the ball drop
uh what kind of Nefarious activity are
you going to be involved in what are you
doing I don't know are you gonna drink
you know smoke
gonna have sex I don't know what kind of
Nefarious activity
the right you've got to know that the
right absolutely has to hate New Year's
right
they have to hate it like it's got to be
the worst holiday for them ever
it's it's insanity
they're like oh drugs booze
people horny people
that's gross can you imagine oh my God
um MJ says at least five Edibles God
damn
MJ's not gonna [ __ ] around this weekend
woo
Amanda says uh uh I'll be probably be
drewing asleep she must go to bed early
uh Louise from Facebook says staying
home not not gonna participate
now Jared from YouTube says all the
above you know all that stuff all that
great stuff
all the stuff that the right hates that
they don't want us to do I want to do
that
I want to do that our new moderator the
Cynthia rice says I'll be staying at
home
what do you be doing at home though
you're going to be watching movies you
know watch the ball drop what are we
doing at home if we're staying at home
oh Dave Dave Panic on Facebook
you you project way too much son
oh you pre even if I was gay I wouldn't
be ashamed of a dummy
even if I was
you've you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] Dave oh
boy Dave's got Dave here is getting a
real problem
with his uh homosexual feelings I guess
I don't know he's asking uh oh holy [ __ ]
look who we have we have Gabe Sanchez
back hey what's going on how you feeling
my friend you know I've been better I
got a
I got a loading zone right now gluten's
yeah yeah okay good well you're gonna
make it through the bonehead with the
ludens Yeah Yeah Dave Paddock here wants
to know if I'm gonna come out of the
closet in 2023
um wants to know if that's my New Year's
resolution and I told him I was like man
I I even if I was gay I wouldn't be
ashamed of it like I would but also Tony
doesn't own closets so you know I have
no closets no all my [ __ ] is stacked on
the floor no closets I don't I put it in
drawers [ __ ] those closets but Dave it
really does sound like
really does sound like you have a lot of
projection that you're wanting to do in
2023 it really does I bet Dave here
loves Andrew Tate what do you think oh
Andrew taint yeah he loves you oh yeah I
bet David is a huge Andrew fan I also
bet he loves Jerry's Pizza at this point
too oh yeah
Romanian Pizza where were you all this
week for this absolute Drama We the
audience has been missing you and
yesterday listen yesterday how how many
mods may be able to know the time I was
I did like 45 minutes on this two minute
Andrew Tate video 45 minutes
is missing and here's the thing as soon
as I get off the broadcast as soon as I
get off the broadcast I even send you a
message I'm like Jesus this guy is
[ __ ] been arrested for human
trafficking
yeah you're still muted
going through um
okay all right all right so as soon as
soon as soon as I'm off the air so
yesterday's yesterday's episode doesn't
include any of the human sex trafficking
stuff no no no no no I mean as soon as
you as soon as you air for full context
yeah uh I finally got covered
oh okay well I I knew you did and I
didn't I didn't want to yeah yeah I
didn't want to out you and and dox your
covid to the audience I just told them
that you weren't feeling very well
um but you are you are you are positive
for covid but you are not pregnant right
you yeah yeah at least that's that you
took it yes the test I took it was a it
was a one Stripe Right uh okay because
just so Dave knows or it was rather it
was two it was two separate Stripes but
now like a plus you know just so Dave
knows all of us soy boys when we take a
covet test we take a pregnancy test too
just to be safe I I want to be I just
need to make sure that uh
uh what type of Health bills I'm gonna
deal with you know Paddock so so you got
code you traveled for the holidays my
guess is that's how you get covered I
got covered
because my uh
my girlfriend got covered okay oh we
didn't know so she went out one night
for a friend's birthday I was like do
you want to go out and I was like no I'm
working I don't know I was like I was
like I'm working on it what was that I
gotta finish this oh great it was the
which was the nft one yeah they did
someone just said that that was uh they
loved that one by the way oh and I
brought that comment in I'm gonna is
that the last that was the last one that
you did that was the one yeah that was
released it was a merry Christmas you
got several you've been writing but you
haven't been able to do them I guess I
can't because I sound like this I
probably won't be able to record another
one until maybe tomorrow or the next day
okay which is fine because I've got some
ideas of stuff I want to do like George
Santos another one but anyway I digress
we were supposed to go out for a
friend's birthday you didn't go and I
didn't go I was like I'm working on what
was that for the fans for the fans you
got to get that content out and I stayed
in
so then we travel to her parents house
yeah you were in a car we're in a car
right so she's she is she's got covered
she's fine she's fine at this point
right but she had she she's got it but
she just she's got it but she doesn't
have she doesn't know that she has it
right so we stop we get uh we get in and
out you know we share a milkshake you
know we have like in and out there kind
of yeah it's yeah it's whatever I've had
unlike Taco Bell taco but
I think in and out is fine so my
favorite all right all right anyway
so uh we're in the car we're sharing
food drinks whatever
right I'm sure you've kissed her in this
period of time too yeah yeah she's your
girlfriend yeah yeah
and then beyond that
uh yeah it's we so then we get to her
parents house and you know Close
Encounters we're all hanging out talking
whatever having dinner we share a beer
and then she's like oh within like 30
minutes she's like scratchy through
she's like some I feel kind of weird
right now so we both go take a test she
tests possible test the covet test or
the pregnancy test yeah yeah the kova
test oh okay okay just I'm just making
sure there's not a little Gabe Sanchez
running around yeah no no no okay okay
I'm already a child I'm I don't know
so
she tests positive for covid I test
negative boom isolation starts everyone
wears their masks I'm in a set I'm in
like the childhood bedroom up in
upstairs you know so so you're isolating
because you don't have it
yeah because I didn't because I didn't
test positive and so so we isolate and
then the next uh couple days I'm totally
fine so it was the 23rd the 24th I'm
fine no symptoms I test again the 25th
yeah well no it was the day after
Christmas that you text me you're like I
feel like [ __ ] yeah yeah so the 20 the
20 the 25th I test uh negative but I
kind of had a scratchy throat and I was
like okay fine whatever it's coming the
morning of the 26th I test again
negative again oh man but now it's like
a little bit more scratchy throat so
then we're like you know what it's just
best that we drive home we stay the
holidays we'll just drive back
whatever's happening on the way back is
when my body starts to feel like achy
and my temperatures start to get warm
the 27th
and uh at the 27th is when I woke up and
I was like dude I can't come on the show
I'm dead
um
look how nice
pile of [ __ ] oh God damn dude I did get
covered you [ __ ] idiot
it's like you listen to nothing what I
[ __ ] said anyway I got covered I'm
now on the mend I've done my like sweaty
nights breaking news your taste no I
didn't lose my case it sounds like from
what I've read a lot of people uh a lot
of people now uh don't really have that
it's more of the initial like novel
version and the
and the version that was after that but
yeah I I have friends that they lost
their taste like really bad because they
had covered like that first yeah yeah
2020 and they still can't eat certain
things because it tastes weird I have
heard some people who got the flu
after getting covered and it like
restarted everything right and then and
then so like you should be trying to get
the flu to get your taste back I don't
know but what I've what I've read is
some people were saying like oh yeah
I've got uh I got the flu and then
my like senses like how does that affect
the 5G though that's what I want to know
I think there was slight disruption okay
it's like disruption but I think I think
now I'm like on 7g so oh really because
you got the upgrade but I will say this
I did have the booster I got the booster
uh and I got kovitz and I'm like [ __ ]
double double oh man you're you're gonna
be fantastic but this one is pretty I
mean where are these bonehead assets I'm
looking for these dude right to where
they should be go in the folder
oh there they are hey there yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay go ahead go ahead while
I'm uh oh no that's all I was gonna say
that's it that's it yeah let me ask you
let me ask you because um I know some
people in the chat probably give me [ __ ]
about this but um Andrew Tate and then
Elon post and we're going to talk about
this a little bit oh yeah I can't wait I
haven't been able to talk about this
[ __ ] for a week in the inline posted
this [ __ ] this morning did you see this
yeah this [ __ ] Andrew Tate [ __ ] what
does he think the Matrix is real
basically this is what everyone thinks
it's all under this full idea that
everyone needs to get
woken up right can't be wrong yeah I've
got to wake up you got a red pill right
right so you gotta unlearn you got to be
unlearned and all kinds of [ __ ] so
there's this whole Theory out there
right now that
um and we could break it down when we
get into Andrew Tate but there's this
Theory uh that basically says that right
now
uh this is the The Matrix is trying to
control him he's trying to get out of
the Matrix and this is the first sign
this is the first attempt
it's [ __ ] crazy man and that's just
oh he's like a [ __ ] or he's just saying
this [ __ ]
I think a lot of it's confirmation bias
honestly okay what because I just got
done talking about the difference
between opinion and belief because just
because you have a belief does not mean
it's an opinion an opinion is based in
fact like it's Tethered to some sort of
reality this is a movie it's not a
documentary it's not a docu-series this
came from someone's imagination for you
to be entertained you [ __ ] boneheads
why why why is the rights it's so
they're so bad at understanding art they
they just
I I don't I don't know if it's like a
thing that we have failed at in our
education system to explain what art is
to Children yeah but like literally they
it's in it's Insanity it's insane I
think you don't understand how art works
it's right well also it's not even art
it's just like a complete
misrepresentation I mean you look at Ben
Shapiro earlier this week which I would
like would have loved that they're going
to dig into the glass honey thing to
watch it oh yeah yeah I really enjoyed
it I really tried to run it for the
audience the people who didn't watch it
because we did this on Tuesday but yeah
yeah you weren't here but like I wasn't
here but what I will say is like that's
another example where somebody somebody
doesn't quite understand it or they
misunderstand it and they misinterpret
it to be like oh this is what it's
actually about so when someone watches
the Matrix and they say oh this is what
it's actually about and these are the
bad people and this is what it means
take the red pill versus the blue pill
and then you've got you know that's
where red pill blue pill [ __ ] comes from
right yeah yeah
I have I have I probably pissed you off
doing this too I've never watched The
Matrix oh wow the first one's the first
one is good the second and third and the
fourth one is garbage yeah I mean it's
it's I'm probably gonna piss a lot of
people the first one is the best and
that's like the only one that really
probably gonna really piss people off I
don't like Keanu Reeves I'm not a fan
theory is a really nice guy I mean he
might be a nice guy but I'm just I'm not
into it some people are you know some
people aren't fans of his acting you
know or like they're like yeah he's he's
an actor yeah wow but some people I mean
people and you call that you call that
act I mean it I call it Keanu Reeves in
a costume is what well some people
believe that the reason this is what
some people say some people say that the
reason the Matrix or or Keanu Reeves is
so good in The Matrix is because he's
completely
like not aloof but like
unaware of what's going on so he's
learning as the audience is learning
yeah but when you go from him being as
like whoa Bill and Ted well you know
like from that I mean yeah yeah to whoa
you know like when he's same [ __ ] I mean
30 years difference 30 40 yeah same [ __ ]
right
I really enjoyed it I'll tell you I'm a
big fan of the the John Wick movies oh
really well I have not seen that either
come on this year listen the only movie
that I've ever watched with Keanu reason
that I liked was The Replacements and I
think because it had jeans Replacements
is good yeah Replacements is good
because there's Gene Hackman it's
funnier than [ __ ] it's funnier and [ __ ]
that's a great movie that's a great game
that's a good field time like I think
2000 yeah that's an old movie yeah it
doesn't feel like a dead old but it is
it's that old uh let's do this let's
just I I know this is going to be a
shitty transition here but I've already
taken two breaks should we take another
one no let's just let's just go ahead
first are you ready ready for this to go
ahead first into this is how it happens
bone end of the week you see that boom
boom boom because we're already almost
two hours and we got a lot of [ __ ] to
talk about because I know you got a
great story for the audience about this
Andrew Tate thing so let's do this let's
do the bonehead intro bonehead of the
week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's edition of
bonehead of the week Gabe Sanchez I'm
glad you're back with us
oh boy there was a lot of boneheads to
choose from last night we were really
like there's a whole list of them and
we're like who is it and even this
morning we're like okay this person that
person I don't know we maybe need to
have more categories or something but
here here are the conditions contestants
that ended up on the bonehead of the
week poll that the audience had a chance
to vote on
um Andrew take course that story is um
high profile right now everyone's
wondering well they're not really
wondering he's a piece of [ __ ] he's been
a piece of [ __ ] I mean obviously him
being a human trafficker isn't a big
surprise I guess but there's also
another fraud on the list George Santos
just any other average typical
Republican who won a seat in Congress
everyone wants him to resign
I just want everyone to admit that every
Republican is as much of a fraud as
George Santos and then we have someone
who really denies who they really are
Kyle Rittenhouse the murderer
um why are these three the ones that
ended up on the list well yeah as we
know Andrew Tate or should we start with
let's start with Kyle let's let's yeah
we can start with Kyle right now let's
start with let's get let's get that
little [ __ ] out of the way really yeah
yeah
written house I don't know little little
crybaby murderer [ __ ] [ __ ] the
reason he's on the list this week is
because he really has made a push now
he's been doing it for a while but he
really made a push during uh the
holidays to ask for money to to put
himself as the victim and say oh my God
guys I'm the victim even though I was
exonerated or whatever the [ __ ] he wants
to claim he was
he wants to push the idea that he is not
someone who killed someone actually
that's a good example you scroll up I
see which one you look at it see the
four photos of him
this one here no no no this one here
yeah that one that one that one okay
Ryan Ryan yeah so that's an example of
four different posts now he's done it
more than this but these are four posts
that that Kyle made
over the holidays this is on his account
on his account thank you to everyone who
has sent prayers donations and kind
messages that really mean a lot during
this Christmas season any amount helps
fight this lawsuit which is an attack on
our god-given right to self-defense
actually no it's because you brought a
[ __ ] AR-15 assault style rifle to a
place with people that nobody asked you
to be at that you didn't actually own
the gun in a state that you didn't live
in
so I'm sorry that there are consequences
for the actions of you killing two
people and shooting a third
guilty he keeps posting this link here's
another one thank you guys so much for
the generosity I've read so many prayers
and kind messages prayers Jesus now
without you guys I would not be able to
cover the cost to fight this lawsuit
you know you've seen a picture up here
his uh Avi yeah his Avatar that's the
one from the uh from the right wing what
the gr the the the the right stuff the
white the white the right stuff yeah
okay yeah
um what a [ __ ] box so this is why this
is why we put him on because he's a
grifting piece of [ __ ] so wait a second
so because here he is grifting again
here's another one
um
so you're telling me this is why we put
him on bonehead right and he's a grifter
that he's a phony and a Frog yeah he's
just another here's here's the thing
that I find so funny she used to be a
pattern with these three though honestly
it's a these are a bunch of lying
grifting [ __ ] misogynistic women
hating uh Republican uh backing yeah
idiot Maga they're Maga they're they're
the America First Nazi party look
I we have a friend Walter Masterson and
and um I went on one of Walter's streams
I know several months ago and he was
trolling Q Anon he was pretending to be
a q an honor on this stream it's on his
Facebook page
um maybe I'll post the link
um but I asked him I I messaged Walter I
said hey with this Andrew Tate stuff
going on I said do you remember that
stream because he actually went to
Andrew Tate's um website the the hustle
whatever it is hustle Hustler's
University yes that's it that's it so he
went to and of course 2.0 I think is
what it's on whatever it is whatever it
is Walter went to that website on the
stream and he is chatting with someone
and they cut him off like three or four
times because they don't
I forget the question he was asking it's
hilarious maybe I'll post that link um
to Twitter and I hear in a little bit so
you guys can go watch that stream where
Walter is absolutely [ __ ] trolling
whoever is the chat bot on the other
side of Hustler University it's
hilarious it's hilarious it's probably
Andrew Tate or like Tristan Tate his
brother and they're like oh yes this is
exactly what we need to say and then
they realize that
I mean that's here I will say this and
I'll and I will mention this once again
Andrew Tate there is a theme amongst
people within the right Maga these Alpha
[ __ ] Bros all this [ __ ] when they
don't like what you say or the fact that
you just ask a question that you know
doesn't require a complex answer or a
roundabout let me like walk around
eggshells give you this uh convoluted
answer you know
they will block you they will cut you
off they will stop you they are the ones
who actually stop you from from speaking
and and voicing your opinion and being
able to have free speech the first
amendment that they love have you seen
this new bill in Montana there's there's
apparently a bill in the Montana
legislator where they're trying to make
any any kind of drag thing
as sex you have to have a sexual license
is what they're calling it or some [ __ ]
but they literally like is that the show
like oh my birth certificate says this
literally they absolutely they they they
they they asked the papers Tony where
are the papers that's what that sounds
like they absolutely they absolutely are
cancer culture they are like some people
are like oh there's no such things can't
no it is the right wing those are the
ones who want to cancel you they don't
want you to be who you are they don't
want you to believe what you want to
believe they do not they they don't want
it because it's a threat to them
um so let's just do this let's just get
right into the Andrew Tate stuff
um because there's a whole Saga here now
you have your own story but I want to go
back here
and really show the audience
um the story that the lead up yeah um
what this what the well I mean
you know I didn't know this about Andrew
Tate now I went to make the thumbnail on
the other day because you weren't
feeling well and I think I did a pretty
pretty damn good job yeah
I think I did a pretty good job of the
thumbnails this week you know even
though it's me saying it I'm just saying
they were awesome
um but I went to make the thumbnail and
I was looking for a really stupid
picture of Andrew Tate course I just
took a screenshot of him flashing his
nipple yeah on the video he said I'm
glad you picked that one that worked
great that worked great but um but I
went to look for a stupid picture of him
so I Googled him because I really don't
immerse myself in a lot of Andrew take
content because I know he's just a [ __ ]
box and I know he's just a really big
internet troll apparently human
trafficker too I don't know if you've
heard that recently but not only that
but also a woman beater domestic there's
a lot of allegations against him oh so I
mean there's literal videos oh okay well
yeah maybe we'll we'll take a look but
here's the thing
I Google him I had no idea
no clue
that he is a kickboxer and apparently
up until his last fight that he had with
Greta he had a lot of wins this guy was
not a bad kickboxer um it's just too bad
that he didn't stick to sport
and he didn't just keep kicking he was
also on Big Brother
what he was on the boat he was on Big
Brother UK that's before he shaved his
head and went all [ __ ] badass
uh but he was on really so there's a lot
of footage of him before he was
yes and before he like I mean like he
was like muscular before but then he was
like whoa when all [ __ ] swole on this
[ __ ]
so he's yeah he's definitely yeah right
dude the boy is juicing it's not just a
it's he's not just on a broccoli rice
chicken kind of diet the dude is Juicy
oh [ __ ] he's doing more than just
natural protein huh oh yeah but he he
was on Big Brother UK and he was
actually on that show I think for about
a week
on the UK version and then the video
came out about that was of him beating
his girlfriend with a belt
and then he got kicked off the show
oh so they they they bounced him while
he was on the show because of the video
so the the UK publication I think it was
the mirror wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait back up back up back yeah yeah did
you just say
that he was hitting his girlfriend
that's what I said there's a video
there's videos online about this so this
is what happened there's a video of him
uh beating his girlfriend at the time
with a belt right pretty aggressively
yelling saying I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you if you're talking about man all this
[ __ ] right
so it was like a jealous rage thing is
what you're saying well so this is what
happens so and this is also what was
discussed yesterday in this uh Twitter
space that I was in but what happened
we'll get there yeah we'll get there but
basically in this video
it comes out then after he goes oh no no
it was edited this is like uh this is
not real kind of thing the Matrix yeah
yeah this is oh this is this is from 10
years prior and blah blah blah uh and
then after well look Gabe Sanchez you
can't trust video that's over six months
once a video is aged six months it's
definitely just like it definitely
automatically edited it's not yeah right
so that is what happened for people
asking if I'm saying it's about Andrew
Tate yes this is Andrew Tate on on video
with his girlfriend at the time hitting
her with the belt
while he was on the TV show Big Brother
2016. now he's from Britain but but on
his profile when you Google but he's an
American American British yes
I think he grew up in Chicago or
something that's what he says that's
what he says he says he's a group in
Chicago yeah
there's no telling what yeah you know
yeah it's um it's a whole thing his dad
was a
and I think a well-known or a a
a good
uh chess player so he plays chess
but he always brags but he's like oh I
won the age Under 12 when I was five
years old three years in a row whatever
I don't really care whether you play
Chestnut so this video comes at your
[ __ ] human this video comes out he
loses his spot on the big brother kicked
out right and then we we fast forward
yeah yeah we fast forward during that
time he kind of begins to re rebranding
stage he starts his master University he
goes on podcast well yeah and he starts
kickboxing all that stuff and then he go
and then he starts this podcast and this
this pyramid scheme because look at you
guys the pyramid pyramid scheme of
paying fifty dollars per month to attend
Hustler University which basically was
just him bragging about all the [ __ ]
crimes that he did wait wait wait so
Hustler University doesn't teach you
anything no it teaches you how to
basically the way Hustler University
teaches you that you should give him
fifty dollars yeah it was pay me fifty
dollars and I'll teach you this is how
an Internet payment works because he's a
lifestyle Guru and so he teaches you how
to be confident and a man and an alpha
man all this [ __ ] well let's let's
see how alpha he is because here is
what got him in hot water in the last
few days
he he
um you know regretta thundberg is
she's pretty well known climate activist
she's a teenage climate and she's still
a teenager because she's 19 right
so he he tags her now for those who
aren't familiar with Twitter
if you want to get someone's attention
one way to do it
is to tag their account because what
happens when you tag their account
is it ends up in their notifications
so here Andrew Tate says hello at
Greta thumb Burke which is her Twitter
handle he tags her so she'll see it
now it's completely unprompted he just
came out of the gate and was like yo
right
now this first statement here is
hilarious
it's [ __ ] hilarious he says I I she's
never she probably didn't even know who
the [ __ ] he was yeah until she saw this
in her notifications I have 33 cars now
first off
and we're gonna get to the small dick
energy but this is one of the most small
dick energy statements I have ever seen
hello at Greta thundberg I have 33 cars
this is number one he doesn't have 33
cars I went over this he may own a few
cars but he does not own all those cars
he takes pictures with he rents those
cars He leases those cars he takes
pictures with him he returns them it's
just like he doesn't have a private jet
he Charters right and he takes all kinds
of photos yeah yeah right and then he
recycles the [ __ ] he probably again the
clothes that he's even wearing he
probably rents those to put the clothes
on so he can take the pictures now he
goes on to claim my Bugatti my two
Ferraris you know and he says this is
just the start
now he asked her to please provide your
email address
so that I can send a complete list of my
car collection and their respective
enormous emissions now I think what he's
trying to say here Gabe Sanchez I think
what his goal here was was to get a
teenager's a female teenager's email
number one
but he's trying to own a lib right this
is his goal here this is what he's
attempting to do for his audience this
is content that he's creating for his
Hustler University goers whatever they
do when they go to Osler University he's
trying to prevent he's trying to provide
own the libgard content now
it kind of backfires on him a little bit
just
just a smidge because here is how Greta
thundberg who probably had no idea who
Andrew Tate was yeah when she received
this note she got a she got a quick
whiff of a Google Search and maybe a
quick scan of his speed and was like I
know exactly who this is
30 seconds of Andrew Tate talking into a
microphone and understand what kind of
[ __ ] box he is and no you can you can
literally if you have no idea who Andrew
Dade is never watched a video of him
watch one video of him talking for 30
seconds you will know every single every
single opinion that he has on any issue
any of them like you will know exactly
what he's going to say before he says it
that's how vile and gross he is now
Greta thundberg does Humanity a favor
here by quote tweeting Andrew Tate now
she definitely could have just ignored
this yeah this would end up in her
notifications she could ignore it he
would probably tweet at her several more
times right and she would do the proper
thing that most people would do that
have a profile that she has not to
platform him just to leave it alone and
not say anything just let it Breeze over
right maybe what he was expecting
possibly but she doesn't do that Gabe
Sanchez she proceeds to wad him up into
you know when you pick a really slimy
booger oh yeah and it's like I mean it's
huge it's like hanging off your finger
and you wad it up
into a real hard ball and then you fling
it across the room that's exactly what
Greta vanberg did here to this [ __ ]
booger Andrew Tate she says yes please
do enlighten me she forgot the [ __ ]
part please do enlighten me [ __ ]
email me at small dick energy
getalife.com this is hilarious I mean I
I honestly I had no idea that that this
was part of Greta Thunder's personality
I mean you you see the video when Trump
walks past her and she's just like
shooting laser eyes through it yeah yeah
but this I had no idea and I'm so
excited about this part I mean she's
she's reused uh I think when Trump after
Trump lost the re-election and the last
day of his like you know presidency he
was like okay bye you know
uh but what ended up happening was I
think she recycled
the same phrasing of one of the tweets
that she that he had towards her because
he he sent a couple tweets one was like
oh Greta has anger management problems
she needs to chill Greta watch a movie
kind of [ __ ] why do these toxic males
have this thing for her what the [ __ ] oh
man well I you know it well really what
it is it's control right it's control
it's it's she's got a voice she's got
power she's smart right but if I
embarrass this person it's like if
anyone's seen the movie Matilda not the
new one that's on Netflix but the old
one the older one with with Danny the
vienni DeVito he goes I'm big you're
small I'm old you're young I'm smart
you're dumb I'm right you're wrong that
whole thing that's what that's exactly
what Trump does and that's what exactly
is what entertain alpha males do they
try to they try to one-up someone who
hasn't challenged them right it's the
same type of [ __ ] that you see with
Republicans when when someone from the
lgbtq community is like I'm living my
life and then they come kicking in the
door and like yo the [ __ ] you were and
you're like I never said anything to you
I don't why are you in my house right I
don't want you even in my universe the
same type of [ __ ] if they can if they
basically it's like a very colonizer
type of mentality they kick in the door
they come through well well easy on the
colonizers I'm just saying they break it
down the door they trash the house and
then they say
uh you are at fault you're the problem
he embarrass you and I was like wait I
don't even know who the [ __ ] you are
where did you come from right where did
you sail from creeping on me why did you
where did you sail from across this body
water come [ __ ] with our society well
here is
here's his response to the email now
this took several hours for Andrew Tate
to come up with which is not surprising
that it took him trying to figure this
out another person who says they are a
mad genius right well
it really is something last night I got
a teenage son and our universe is
collided last night with Andrew Tate
because he comes in the kitchen and he's
like did you hear that Andrew Tate got
arrested on I'm like I did 45 minutes on
my show on this and he's like you know
who Andrew Tate is and like
unfortunately yes I do now know who this
idiot is
but here's the thing here's his response
and Gabe you do a lot of parody in
satire and I believe that's what he's
attempting to do here and again the
right does not understand art they don't
understand jokes they don't understand
comedy they don't get humor and they
definitely do not know how to form a
good parody or satire because they are
the parody or satire like they are it
you are the embodiment of the birdian
center
but here he tweets he quote tweets
Greta's you know small dick energy get a
life that can
and he says thank you for confirming
via your email address that you have a
small penis at Greta thundberg he he
[ __ ] tags her again dude this is
desperate [ __ ] because he's quote
tweeting her
he's quote tweeting her which would
automatically go in notifications he's
got to know this right right Sanchez but
he's tagging her anyways
the world was curious and I do agree you
should get a life he had hours to write
this hours to Wordsmith this tweet in
which he's going to post with this
stupid [ __ ] cringe ass video
now the video has got a lot of attention
but this tweet has not got a lot of
attention
because of the the pizza box in the
video but this tweet has to be just as
bad or worse than the video literally I
don't know how many people are in this I
know there's six females that he was
holding hostage apparently in this house
and there's his brother and a couple
other dudes that were arrested
but how in the [ __ ] were they sitting
around and this is the best they come up
with well this is the typical like oh
thanks for confirming your you know when
she's like oh thank you for confirming
via your email address that you have a
small penis it's one of those things
where somebody leaves a response open
and you're like oh I do agree they're a
bad person right because they don't
Define which person they're talking
about or anything
it's a very easy thing to do and I've
done it before too and it sometimes
shuts up a troll to be like oh and then
they they kind of go away but
this is one of those things where I'm
like really
uh I mean yeah I guess you know what
this is totally understandable but when
you do that in the thread not as a quote
tweet and you tag them this is
desperation I mean this account this
account that he has that Elon Musk gave
back to him which is a whole nother
story yeah
um which um we have Elon in the bonehead
here so we might get into that part of
the story but he has 3.8 million
followers yeah he's also a 36 year old
dude trying to pick a fight unprompted
just like
33 cars [ __ ] right like what
with a 19 year old girl oh my God now
the the real story here is because this
is all funny and cringe and it's easy to
mock this but the real story is Andrew
Chait and his brother are on the run and
the reason why they're on the run is
because they've been flying around the
world apparently holding women against
their will and I guess the way I read it
Gabe Sanchez is from these reports from
the some of the Romanian officials that
have that have given statements about
why they arrested them apparently they
were trafficking them around the world
the U.S the UK Romania
um and they were holding women against
their will or lying to them to to get
them at will to be there and they're
shooting porno for a special website
that's what I'm gathering now I don't
know what website it is they run a cam
girl okay so it is a cam girl situation
which again again I'm not against porn
I'm not against consensual people doing
whatever the hell they want to do you
know your Kink is your Kink whatever but
when you're holding a women against the
will especially I think some of these
are underage women I'm not really sure
they didn't confirm the ages but they're
well apparently they're those two women
that they were looking for right
there's an American there was an
American girl there's a British girl but
I guess supposedly one of them I don't
know if it's those two or the other
girls but one of them is a minor so
right that's not great so so so that is
the real story here is that and keep in
mind this is this is an international
uh and we'll get into this more later
too but this is an international crime
this is not just like the Romanian
authorities being like we gotta hunt
this down this is multiple countries
right investigating this Interpol was
involved and everything else now and
that's the actual story here is that
Andrew Tate and his brother the the
personalities that go online and you
know they want to own the libtards and
and Matrix and there's a big conspiracy
theory against them well the conspiracy
theory is that they they are they are
being uh criminals they have a crime a
human trafficking ring and the
authorities are trying to shut down
their criminal trafficking ring where
they're trafficking humans so that's the
conspiracy against them
um but it's crazy because this video
that he post is so cringe but in true
um
and true Andrew Tate Style
the dumb [ __ ] that comes along with
all this Saga against Greta thundberg is
that he doxes himself in this video now
let's watch this video in full which I
have there's more details of this but
yeah let's play this video Let's watch
this video on voice two minutes it's
cringe as [ __ ] you will laugh when you
when you're watching it but I'm not I
promise I won't pause it
release some greenhouse gases
God
I'm obviously a stranger to online
controversy it's not something I often
do
but now
the mainstream press is commenting on
the fact that
I was informing Greta that my very
extensive car collection with internal
combustion engines which run on dead
dinosaurs had an enormous emission
profile
and she replied by telling me her own
email address
Greta's email address is I have small
dick energy
why would that be your own email address
for
strange
I mean also I don't want to assume her
gender it's 50 50. but
it is what it is
I'm not actually mad at Gregory
please bring me pizza and uh make sure
that these boxes are not recycled
thank you so I'm actually mad at Greta
right because she doesn't realize she's
been programmed she doesn't realize
she's a slave of the Matrix she thinks
she's doing good someone has sat her
down and convinced her
to try and convince you to beg your
government
to tax you into poverty to stop the Sun
from being hot
and then because I called her out on it
the global Matrix got this bot Farm oh
[ __ ] to like and retweet and all this
bought commenting to try and pretend
that her telling me that she has a small
dick in her own email address
somehow teaches meals
welcome to the new episode of the clown
show
but now I know at least
that Greta with a little hate-filled
face
bitter sitting somewhere without the
eating on in the cold little hot
shivering
use my Tweets we're just gonna make my
Twitter account far more fun into
attorney
okay Gabe Sanchez there's a lot to
unpack here I just want to go back to
the very last statement that he says
here because I tried to point it out for
the audience
that this chucklehead tagged her he
tagged her Twitter account she did not
notice this tweet
he made sure she saw this tweet because
it was unsolicited that's the other
thing too here is he plays like he's the
victim of Greta attacking him did you
notice that that's any time anyone
anyone who
gets called out or gets made fun of
they're immediately going to be I'm the
victim I'm we see with Trump we see with
Don Jr we see with Jared Kushner oh well
Jesus we saw it with David Paddock here
in on Facebook he's cheating oh yeah
he's attacking me I bring him up and
then he's gone he's invisible I mean
after he that was one of those things
where he's like uh yeah it just but it's
the same [ __ ] it's that's why I know
Dave loves this [ __ ] chucklehead
that's on the screen now I'm sure that
he has been
a proud subscriber of the Hustler
University scam he's probably jerking
he's probably jerked off to plenty of
Andrew Taylor oh yeah easily yeah yeah
but but here I want to point out
something this pizza box thing is really
kind of what it has got has crushed the
the human trafficking ring and here's
why is because number one what the why
the I I questioned this yesterday why
did he have the pizza boxes brought in
other than to own the lips they seem
empty do they seem empty to you uh no
they look they I it doesn't look like
there's Pizza in there look I I don't
think there's I mean maybe some
leftovers uh yeah I don't know I mean it
looks like it looks like a wannabe
Domino's box right well I mean it's
probably the same box just different
print but there is a there is a QR code
here which is very interesting yeah yeah
that's very interesting it's almost like
that's what the Romanian officials right
to figure out which [ __ ] place
you're like yeah they're like which one
did you order from right but the the
other thing is uh in my like
uh covid delusional State the other day
I
watched this video and I was like what
is Jerry's Pizza and I thought about it
and I was like I'll Google it later and
then I just and then I fell asleep and I
took a nap and I woke up and then I
completely forgot about it and then you
fast forward like 16 hours and it and
then you find out that the pizza box was
a clue to his location well because they
did not because
where they arrested him was his
brother's Villa right right right now
they knew his brother owned this Villa
they knew that they possibly could be
there but they couldn't confirm it and
the pizza boxes are what confirmed it
that yes they are at that villa which
gave them the ability to go arrest them
right so it turns out though it wasn't
just the pizza box okay what else there
were other things that were posted so
Andrew Tate had also posted a video on
Twitter of him in a mountainous region
of Romania
where he has reported to be lit or has
lived last five years
and that was the first indication that
he was in that country and that's what
originally tipped them off the pizza box
was like another one it wasn't the thing
that got him busted oh but we want it to
be though right oh yeah totally totally
I just for anyone out there who's like
well actually I'm just gonna stay right
there the pizza part it it played a big
role let's let's just say uh they put
the part in pizza party okay it played a
part in this whole thing
but he also had other things that uh
flagged where he was right and so this
whole like [ __ ]
why did he do this why because because
he saw a 19 year old girl's tweet
[ __ ] own him I mean just go back to
her original tweet ready go back to her
original tweet so yeah we're gonna
follow we're gonna follow this back
ready so go to her tweet
okay here it is all right now scroll
down
scroll down scroll down scroll down
scroll down scroll down okay let's go
back up let's go let's go back up
258.2 million views now obviously this
is after the fact right now this is a
new Elon thing by the way
yeah yeah it's it's now anyone who
missed it uh it's a bunch of vanity
metrics it doesn't [ __ ] mean [ __ ]
right anyway so because it's also like
oh 258 million people saw this but then
how many does a video have when it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so this tweet which has
3.6 million likes 258.2 million views
all right this is Andrew Chait also
responding to be how dare you because
he's mocking Greta and of course Hassan
and true style right um gets in and on
the conversation you're trying to beef
with teenagers instead of adults and
still losing right is wild so let's go
to the original tweet that she quote
tweeted right
okay this one here yeah so remember it
was 3.6 million likes and 258 million
views now you look at this one
160.5 million views
219.4 million thousand likes okay 219
000 likes 3.6 million likes she got on
her response even people on the right
were [ __ ] ratioed we're laughing at
just what this is called right this is
this is called a ratio this is this is
when your [ __ ] your your comment or
your quote tweet outperforms the
original one and this is what happened
here he got [ __ ] shoved into a little
cuck box
and got [ __ ] owned by a 19 year old
girl a 36 year old alpha male kickboxing
with a Bugatti of all the Bugatti two
Ferraris
three cars [ __ ] how many cars do
you think Greta Van how many cards you
think Grand of Thunder owns how many one
shows a bicycle a bicycle so she owns a
bicycle
and she got how many [ __ ] likes how
many millions
3.6 million and post a picture of what
is supposedly his Bugatti yeah and he
only gets 219 000. dude Andrew if you
ever get out of prison man you need to
buy a bicycle might help your ratio my
friend okay so but so here's here's
here's the thing there is more to this
story because again you go to we go back
to the actual video and here's here's
the video now this is crazy to me
because this video here's the Tweet with
the video it's got 16 million views on
the video the the actual tweet has 57
almost 59 right this is why the whole
this is why these vanity metrics news on
actual tweet means it's all [ __ ] but
here but but look at this look at the
likes
only 247 000 likes yeah the same amount
of likes that were on the original
[ __ ] tweet it seems like if there's
Bots I'm just saying if there's Bots
seems like there's something he also
through he also started uh
complaining that there was a conspiracy
of a bunch of bots that were only going
to like her posts and not his post
all right well right but here's here's
the thing here's the thing this Saga is
not over I mean obviously he's gonna you
know be caught on these charges it looks
like uh I'm following Along on some
people who are reporting on it and they
were waiting on a judgment
but it looks like
they can be held in multiple stints of
30 days
so well because of the charges that they
placed on in Romania the way I
understand it the reporting that I was
watching is that those charges have no
bail and they do it in a special way in
Rome in Romania because of the charges
and basically they're not going to get
out well yeah they're also keep in mind
for for those who are listening or
watching the the prosecutor that is
presiding over this case is of it's kind
of like a Jack Smith situation
so this guy also presided over a uh uh
Marion behind case which is an Infamous
drug lord found guilty on four murder
charges
in Romania oh [ __ ] this guy so they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah Andrew dates
[ __ ] but listen
there's one more piece a final piece a
final cherry on top to this Greta
Andrew battle on Twitter and she in so
fine fashion with this new personality
trait that I just love about her and I
think she should do more of this she
tweets this is what all lowercase by the
way all lowercase doesn't even give the
first T and doesn't even [ __ ] worry
about capitalizing it this is what
happens when you don't recycle your
pizza box
oh my God and look at look at the ratio
here
2.4 million likes it's almost and she
didn't have to mention him a quote
it there's no context none
um none
just saying hey you might want to
recycle those pizza boxes might help
next time this is [ __ ] beautiful I
just wanna I just want to say
the
the uh
end of year
2022. this last week alone
holy [ __ ] we've got one more day
obviously a lot more [ __ ] can happen
there'll be more developments I'm sure
we will hear more about this case we'll
probably hear more about Donald Trump's
taxes well because obviously those are
released today we'll definitely hear
more about [ __ ] uh George Santos or
whatever his Alias might be
all of these things kind of like wrapped
up at the end of 2022 almost to imply
that maybe 2023 will be on a better note
right well I I think we're going into
20. I'm honestly like holy [ __ ] man a
lot of this I almost don't want the year
to end now I want to extend it another
week or two you got Jan six stuff coming
out you got taxes coming out you got
Andrew Tate on [ __ ] human trafficking
you got Greta [ __ ] owning him on
Twitter you got George Santos being
investigated by Republican okay New York
so so I want to get to the story about
this Twitter spaces but let's do it in
the Twitter part of this bonehead with
Elon yeah um and I know it might not
have anything to do but I want you to
tell that story but I now that you're
bringing up tax returns
who is the dishonorable mention of this
week who who could not make an
appearance in this book right obviously
obviously is Donald Trump himself the
cute the Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa
poopy pants Donald Trump because not
only is his tax returns dropping today
and we find out the first thing we find
out is this guy's got a Chinese bank
account which is not surprising at all
as much as he talks about China Janet
Hunter's fighting's laptop lives in
China the laptop has a Chinese big
account I mean obviously right how
fitting is it for a guy who always like
Janet Janet Jenna and then to find out
he had a [ __ ] Chinese Bank when he's
PR while he's president not before yeah
wow he's president he's sitting in the
Oval Office making deposits and of
course you hear the Chinese Bank when
his tax return When the report was
released earlier or later last week
uh people were like this is nothing okay
you didn't pay these taxes whatever and
it's like dude this ain't nothing you
ain't seen nothing yet well here's what
I think about the tax returns I think to
expect that this is going to bring any
kind of criminal charges that's not
gonna happen no no not at all but here's
what we should do here's what we should
do with these tax returns we should mock
the ever loving [ __ ] out of him and
every single simp that he has and the
reason why is because the things they
say again it's the Andrew Tate effect
here and the Santos effect Jesus Christ
these people they're all the one and the
same why everyone's so mad that Santos
is a Republican
they're gonna uh
uh they're gonna replace like just
completely Wipe Out the phrase Barbra
Streisand effect right they're gonna
they're gonna be like oh no Streisand
effect what do you mean you mean Santos
effect right the Santa's effect you mean
that's it you mean the Tate effect you
mean the Trump effect that's it well and
and the craziest part is the reason why
he doesn't want these tax returns
released and you see it in this
statement on true social I read it
earlier and if you can grab the link
I'll pull it up it's his statement if
you want to just grab that I'll I'll
pull it up he in the statement he is
trying to tell everyone no don't listen
to him I really am rich
and that's what he's terrified of of
these tax returns he doesn't give a [ __ ]
if it exposes crime he does not care he
only cares about his [ __ ] little
fragile ego and the fraud that he is
Rich and that he is successful the same
way that Andrew Tate had to make that
stupid [ __ ] video because he got
owned by Greta is this is this the um
the official is this the Trump statement
yeah I didn't make this by the way I'm
just saying that to me
uh this is not of Gabe Sanchez is doing
no this is this is really I can't even
believe
we used there was a time when you were
making these yeah yeah and there was one
that got you in real trouble with Seth
Abrams yeah he got really pissed off he
got real pissed off I was he said Gabe
Sanchez is a threat to democracy yeah
right and I've never been more humbled
by that statement
then Seth averson thinking you're a
threat to democracy yeah the the best
part is is that like after that happened
that whole Seth Abramson he he freaked
out that it was fake right because
Daniel dale dale just does the thing
this person is fake right Seth Abramson
is a journalist who got upset that he
shared an image that was shared to be to
appear real and he didn't do his
background or his research and shared it
and then you mean he didn't go to the
website to see if it was there or not or
to do any sort of Google search or or
look at your account to see who the [ __ ]
you are oh my God but he just did it and
he posted and then when people called
him out he said
oh oh oh no no no guys I'm not the idiot
here Gabe is the threat to democracy
because he he he pranked me he made me
believe this was real and then I shared
it to everyone and said it was real I
got cooked so I'm mad but literally
since then we've tried to determine if
there was a good situation where we can
make a fake Trump true social post but
honestly it's not possible anymore
because you can't pretty good job you
can't make them any worse than what he's
doing
but here is part of the statement
um that is released from the 45th this
is so stupid from the 45th president of
the United States of America Jesus
Christ
okay so that I'm gonna read it again
real quick here the Democrats should
have never done it the Supreme Court
should have never approved it and it's
going to lead to horrible things for so
many people yeah there's probably a lot
of people going to go to prison because
of your tax returns that is the truth
the great USA divide will now grow far
worse because of you dumb [ __ ] the
radical left Democrats have weaponized
everything remember blah blah blah blah
blah blah the part I want to get to is
this part right here
he's floating Forbes now one the one
where he lied yeah well here's the thing
is I've talked about Forbes in Prior
weeks not because of Donald Trump
because of Elon Musk the the the broke
as human alive yeah right I have said
that the Forbes list is all [ __ ] the
whole thing it's all you should not
listen to it you should not believe a
single thing it says you should not give
it any weight and how you measure
someone's wealth because it's all
[ __ ] and here Trump is in his
statement in true style almost like we
made this [ __ ] up ourselves quoting
Forbes for me
and he says this is crazy [ __ ] he quotes
it Trump's assets are worth an estimated
4.3 billion which is half of what he
claimed it was in 2016. right when he
was on the key key word here is
estimated right because here's the thing
if people don't know this uh and I would
have to find the
the article or the quote but basically
there was a phone call between uh Trump
and his lawyer was next to him and they
were on the phone who's that lawyer
who's that lawyer uh
do you know who it is
it was
uh
anyways yeah I got let me let me look
into that one but basically on this
phone call Forbes was like hey we need
to verify that Trump actually has as
much money
and they were like okay sure he has this
much money and they're like can you send
us stuff they're like oh well it's a
bunch of papers but we're looking at
right now and the assets say this many
million dollars and this all this
[ __ ] and be like Trump is a and then
that was how he got himself on like the
billion so wait wait wait wait you mean
you mean to tell me that the Forbes list
is not verify actually verified are you
telling me in this one instance they did
not I don't know if they verify other
people but they definitely didn't verify
this one
well here's here's what it goes on to
say he's quoting Forbes here the former
president owns real stuff Mansions golf
courses Office Buildings
that throw off Royal cash
yeah even if his tax returns might
suggest otherwise the DC hotel opened in
2016 by 2018 Trump had already declared
tax losses of 55.5 million there
according to the times still the
property is worth something
he wants so desperately for people to
think that he's Rich Gabe this is
insanity that he his tax returns which
every president has willfully and most
candidates have willfully given the
media their tax returns to thumb through
when they run for president or become
president yeah and we literally because
Joe Biden was the vice president
and because he was a United States
Senator we have decades
Decades of Joe Biden's tax returns
decades
and here this guy is the reason why he
didn't he's telling you in this
statement why he did not want you to see
his tax returns because here's what it
says here's what it says wrong just sold
the hotel for almost 400 million many of
their other numbers are wrong too but by
even bigger proportions but that's okay
being wrong doesn't matter to the fake
news what he's saying is what he's
saying is is I'm worth more than they
can verify and it's it's it's Insanity
because he owns these properties right
because that's going to be his claim
that of course I'm rich I own this golf
course but he doesn't actually own them
the debtor owns them Whoever has the
note owns that [ __ ] he doesn't own them
and this is this is all just ridiculous
so garbly dude but the other word right
do you remember who John Barron is
um yeah he kind of sounds like Trump I
think he has a mustache though does he
write
so John so for people who don't know
John Barron is one of the aliases that
Trump has used in the past right and he
would he would use it to call the media
right right to pimp stories exactly and
so this is what happened so this is the
this is I was trying to remember the the
facts of the story here and I just
wanted to get it right so in 1984 okay
an official from the Trump organization
called this reporter at Forbes to tell
him how rich Donald Trump was right and
this is all this is again this does
involve Roy Cohn and I think if I
remember correctly Roy Cohen is like
kind of The Mastermind how he taught him
how to [ __ ] lie about this [ __ ]
basically he was the supporter was
reporting on the Forbes 400 okay annual
tracking of America's richest for the
third year
in the previous Edition they valued
Trump's Holdings at 200 million only
one-fifth of what he claimed to own
during the interviews this time the aid
urged the reporter on the phone and he
needs to understand just how loaded
Trump really was the official was John
Barron name we now know as an alter ego
of trump himself
John Aaron John Barron I mean if you
want to get technical he really did have
a lot to do with the Trump organization
I mean
it really did I mean right you know to
be quite honest I mean so he was
practically an owner he was practically
an owner right it was oh my God it was
like practically like he was in a room
with Trump all the time oh my god
um Jesus but basically this whole uh and
there's also tapes so it's crazy I'm
gonna do what was that on these on the
finances and the tax returns because I
don't think a lot of people know this
stuff but basically
Trump lied called in as John Barron yeah
this real person right
uh and lied about Trump's wealth to be
like Trump actually owns hundreds of
millions of dollars if not billions of
dollars as time goes on right
and there are tapes that actually prove
that this happened and that he was lying
and that he played into Forbes and
Forbes just took it and they said okay
this guy sounds legit
what do we have to lose here we'll stamp
it and we'll say that he is I mean John
John Barron sounds official it really
does it sounds pretty efficient it
sounds official as [ __ ] so uh Donald
Trump our dishonorable mention of the
week really there's several other
reasons why he could be Baron
John Barron
is is who the dishonorable mention
really oh okay yeah okay so John yeah
John Barron is the actual designer
oh [ __ ] so let's go to let's go to our
Alpha cook of the week
um and I want you to tell the story
because it has to do with Twitter Elon
Musk is the alpha cook the reason why he
ended up Alpha guck is because
um there's a thing where he bought this
company for like 44 billion yeah and he
had this other company I think it used
to be called Tesla I think they're gonna
change have to change the name now or
something Something's Gonna Have to
happen but there's something about a
call on stocks or something where he's
gonna actually avoided it did he yeah he
I read into it yesterday he avoided so
he did avoid this but the the real
reason why he's um suffering here is
because
uh he's losing money faster than Trump
can try to make it up right yeah
um he really is in a lot of trouble but
I mean this ain't stopping anytime soon
well the other thing too is they're
supposed to release another Twitter
files today which is not surprising that
they're going to release their Twitter
files on a day that Trump's tax returns
dropped oh my god oh yeah it's like a
whole nother like you said that it's
like you said that it's almost like it's
almost like they dropped these Twitter
files on the days that they plan to have
bad news about Trump right it's almost
like he's trying to protect Trump and
get him back on his platform or
something but I but since we're on the
topic of Twitter okay since we're on the
topic of Twitter let's talk about
the Twitter spaces that was because
frankly the reason why Andrew Tate is in
the trouble he's in is because Elon gave
him his account back he definitely would
not been able to tweet agretta if Elon
would have not given him his account
back and the experience that you had
last night in the spaces wouldn't have
happened either so tell us tell us about
what happened on Twitter last night
because Andrew Tate just it it caught on
fire right yeah yeah the entire internet
caught on fire but Twitter's especially
right so last night I jumped on you know
I've got a ludens in my mouth uh I'm on
this Twitter space that's hosted
by some people who are very big
he's got a car excuse me there we go
sorry I had a cough it was it's really
catching up on me all right so last
night there was a Twitter space that was
hosted by some of the same people that
dig into these and when I say dig in
they don't really dig in they just kind
of uh have confirmation bias on the
Twitter files right so it's all like a
big circle jerk right yeah yeah you got
a few people in there you always got
[ __ ] Tom fitton who shows up
sometimes John Rich was in there last
night yeah
yeah.com who if anyone doesn't know he's
a [ __ ] Nazi sympathizer who's a
another career criminal who's on the Run
uh for things that yeah he's trying to
he's trying to avoid extradition from is
it New Zealand or where is it from no
he's in he's in New Zealand right he's
trying to avoid extradition from the US
right uh so he he went in there he was
in there last night and talked about how
well about how he's a victim and how
corrupt governments try to come after
you the Matrix yeah the Matrix Matrix so
basically I'm in here and I'm listening
to all these dumb [ __ ] talk about this
[ __ ] and it's pretty crazy but not also
not crazy at the same time it's a bunch
of dudes who are reporting on this and
they say
how do we know that recording yeah
reporting they're like and it's a bunch
it's a bunch of dudes okay it's a bunch
of dudes who are just talking about how
much they so they they uh admire Andrew
Tate he's such a good businessman all
this but some people are saying oh wait
how do we know that Andrew Tate wasn't
being
um investigated by a corrupt Romanian uh
government officials right uh then they
started saying about oh well how do we
know that this wasn't some sort of like
conspiracy to get Andrew Tate as soon as
he was coming back on the platform and
he criticized Greta right there's all
these crazy [ __ ] that was out there
so
in in addition to that there was a
victim blaming the women of course of of
this trafficking ring
uh blaming the Romanian government
and also just completely supportive of
Andrew tape it seems like they were
blaming anyone but the actual right
right which sounds pretty familiar when
you look at how Republicans point
fingers at other people right not
themselves right so this is what happens
I DM the the guy Mario who's hosting the
space
I say hey I got something to say about
Andrew Tate and his human trafficking
ring right and does he put you up as a
speaker so then he brings me up as a
speaker so I've been waiting this whole
time only know oh I couldn't just
message him so I just messaged him
because he and his team are are are uh
holding holding this space right kim.com
is a [ __ ] co-host of the space just
keep in mind this is how things change
later on
so I'm given speaking privileges people
are talking and I'm listening so far and
and we've had women come up now and this
is where the the shift has started right
so you have Eliza blue who is a human
trafficking Advocate but she's a pro
e-line she's a [ __ ] Elon simp she
loves Elon she says the real trauma that
has been experienced from Elon has been
this whole like owning Twitter Twitter
files Elon is the victim so keep that in
mind as you can as you follow this along
she says uh
hey guys
I've been working as a as a human
trafficking Advocate with one of these
victims right so she says she's been
working with someone now an advocate
could be anyone who helps with Logistics
who talks them on the phone who
coordinates uh a visit to the hospital
police whatever right you could do a
little or you could do a lot so Advocate
is a wide spectrum okay we don't know
how much he's done but she claims that
she was to be the she's claiming to work
with this person okay so that's what
that's we'll just put that out there
but Eliza is also very supportive
of
Elon Musk Elon Musk personally allowed
Andrew Tate back on the platform okay
now all of these people are unwilling to
accept the fact that Elon put this guy
on the platform and the guy that he put
on the platform is a bad person
they are unwilling to accept the fact
that Elon might also be and is a bad
person okay
so I get I get seem to be a pattern it
just seems to be the other thing I just
want to uh just this at the stage before
I get into my speaking part there's a
woman who comes in who's in the UK and
was like look I know one of the girls
that uh came forward against Andrew Tate
I am also an expert in the financial uh
services like investigation so when
people commit crimes and you've got a
whole financial
regulators and investigators that come
after you she she begins to comment on
that and she says how everything that
Andrew Tate has done has been illegal
she's like he is in so many words a pimp
if you ever give a gift if you ever do
this if you ever ask a woman to do this
just sleep with this guy or do this
favor for him so that he can return the
favor here this could quid pro quo kind
of thing she calls out
and says if
if all of these things are true which
most likely are based on these reports
uh what he did was illegal and if these
CR these are crimes that don't just go
away right and it's it's almost as if
these dudes in this Twitter space were
just learning about hey maybe women
don't want to be abused maybe this isn't
a healthy relationship to have with
women women aren't objects and the
things that Andrew Tate has said like I
said earlier in the program Andrew Tate
has admitted to these things that he has
done on multiple occasions again and
again and again and whether or not it's
just a Persona or whatever the [ __ ]
is doesn't [ __ ] matter he admitted to
being this alpha male dude who loves
[ __ ] women and women [ __ ] love him
and they're always attracted like
[ __ ] flies on [ __ ] well he is a piece
of [ __ ]
but this guy has openly admitted to the
crimes that he's done and this woman was
like Hey look what he has said and what
he has done I can tell you right now
that it's not looking so good this dude
this lawyer who comes up and says uh
from Romania goes oh yeah one the
Romanian government is corrupt but
they're not gonna get out of this
situation they're in big trouble and
he's like Andrew Tate is not a good guy
well the other thing too even if the
Romanian Governor is corrupt what why
would the last place you want to be in a
pinch in a criminal justice system is a
place where they can well so from so
there are there are and I'd have to find
the interview but I guess in an earlier
interview that Andrew Tate is given and
they talked about why did he pick
Romania to live and all this stuff he
said because the law is so flexible
why would someone need to live in a land
where the law was so flexible is it
maybe because the things that he was
doing was illegal and that he was he was
allowing himself to have legal leeway
but how did he know that Interpol was
going to be after him he didn't know
that
obviously but the dude was I I just
right so what happens is now people are
like yeah she's so distracted by his
Bugatti right right exactly now they've
let they've now let three different
women talk on the subject which I was I
was just impressed by because they had
allowed uh these people to talk okay
they're they're basically saying this
dude's a rapist Andrew Tate and Tristan
Tate are creeps they're Predators uh
they groom a lot of people might be
hearing now the pr uh the lover boy
strategy which is you basically an older
man gets a younger woman you groom them
these guys are groomers they groom them
wait are you saying that that's
projection too oh of course of course so
these guys the Tristan Tate his brother
and Andrew Tate are groomers they're
Predators they're they're rapists
they're sexual they're they're human
traffickers all these things now people
are like oh my God is it just Romania
Romania Romania Romania this all this
[ __ ]
and I'm listening I'm like this is crazy
because one it feels like a lot of these
dudes are just now understanding how bad
of a person Andrew Tate is after they
let these women talk and I'm like oh my
God this is one this is kind of an
eye-opening moment but I was also very
surprised to be like holy [ __ ] a lot of
us already knew this stuff but you guys
who of course are [ __ ] Elon Musk
stands your alpha male uh Free Speech
all this [ __ ] now are like oh wait
wait wait hold on
if Elon Musk put Andrew Tate onto
Twitter right maybe even this shitty
person Elon a bad person too yeah so now
he does the host of the space lets me
talk right so I go into this space and I
say
honestly I am very shocked and surprised
it feels like it sounds like to me that
a lot of you guys never knew this stuff
about Andrew Tate and never knew that he
was a bad person and I very much
appreciate the women who have spoken on
this space because no one at all has has
thanked these women regardless of their
position right because uh there was one
girl who's a transphobe but was calling
out uh Andrew Tate which I was like ah
okay then you have Eliza who's a human
trafficking Advocate but a a Elon simp
and was calling out how bad the stuff
was and I was like ah this is [ __ ]
pulling me at both ends here because
you're not great people but you're
talking about a very shitty person
so I go up and I say I just want to say
thank you especially to the woman who
called out the [ __ ] Financial crimes
aspect because that's where he's going
to get [ __ ] oh yeah
the human trafficking aspect these
crimes just don't go away they stick
with you because here's the thing if he
at any point benefited off these women
at any point in time that [ __ ] just
accumulates it's like a compounded
interest because the money gained there
used to financially benefit somewhere
else to then financially benefit
somewhere else so on and so forth
and this is an Interpol investigation in
international right
this whole idea this whole [ __ ] idea
that oh it was it was the it was the
Romanian government and they're
corrupted another one's coming no no not
at all not at all because what I'll tell
you right now is that there are multiple
countries you've got Romania the US UK
this is
involving multiple countries Interpol is
now involved this is not something you
just [ __ ] make up and they're like oh
okay you know what they're coming it
does sound like Greta snapped her
fingers within a matter of hours like
[ __ ] Thanos right exactly right well
and go ahead go ahead no obviously so
basically the remaining part of my
speech or like my talk was like I just
want to thank the women on here who have
brought the stuff forward because I feel
like a lot of you guys are finally
talking or understanding how bad Andrew
Tate is and then I say I also find I'm
kind of torn here because a lot of you
guys are pro Elon fans
and Eliza as much as I want to say thank
you for being a human trafficking
Advocate she is a huge supporter of Elon
Musk and Elon Musk put Andrew Tate back
on the platform and whether or not
Andrew Tate personally met with Elon
Musk like he posted about on Twitter
wants me to show wants me it basically
makes me believe
or or I want to say that Elon Musk is
not a great person okay and if there's
smoke there is fire Andrew Tate is 100 I
said 100 percent [ __ ] guilty he's a
creep a predator he has a history of
this this is not just a one-time thing
and then they're like well a hundred
percent I don't know about and I was
like all right fine you whatever you
want I mean whatever you gotta do right
whatever you need to feel good about
your cereal soap or what it's 99.99
effective it's like this is up when
there's like oh well then it's not 100
98.7 oh well that's not 100 let's not
say it and so exactly with this I was
like fine whatever it's on a hundred
percent if you don't want to believe it
but I can tell you right now if there
was Smoke there is fire and there is for
sure a [ __ ] fire and these people
were like and kim.com is the real
problem so kim.com who is a guy again if
you want to look him up just Google who
he is all that [ __ ]
he goes and he was the whole time making
jokes he made a joke about the woman who
talked about the financial crime side
because her profile photo was her and
some exotic like uh just uh lingerie
wear right and it had her cleavage
exposed right just you know their
breasts and stuff it wasn't like totally
nude but it had her in this
this kind of like sexy lingerie
kim.com says uh before people talk
can they make sure to put clothes on
and the room goes silent
and I understand exactly what he's
talking about and everyone and
everyone's like what do you got what are
you what are you talking about Kim what
are you talking about and then they
realize they're talking about a profile
photo and then he's like oh I'm just
kidding I'm just joking I'm just joking
so he immediately before she even gets
to talk about her expertise in financial
crimes he immediately tries to to knock
her down a notch by saying we can't take
her seriously because she has lingerie
here's the funny part is in the Andrew
Tate video
he flashes and touches his nipple right
that's the point where I took the
thumbnail right and I guess this all
comes back to rather you think it's a
good thing or a bad thing that Elon Musk
allowed Andrew Tate back on the platform
I mean there's a real real a lot of
reasons why uh Elon Musk could be the
alpha cook this week but I guess that's
the question did he do did he do us a
service by making sure that Andrew Tate
doxed himself or is he what Gabe says
Elon Musk is just a really shitty person
because he let a really shitty person
back on his platform and I wouldn't be
surprised if people were like oh it was
all a [ __ ] long game and yeah
well here's the thing
by the end of it I got kicked out of
that [ __ ] Twitter space yeah because
kim.com who Free Speech remember career
criminal kicked me out by blocking me
then he unblocked me when I showed the
host the like showed him the receipts
and said look this is why I got kicked
out I got unblocked so I was let back in
the Twitter space and then once the
Twitter space ended kim.com blocked me a
[ __ ] oh what a [ __ ] kim.com you're
trying to fight extradition and you're
blocking Gabe Sanchez what a [ __ ] all
because I called him out for being a
bunch of dudes who just now learned that
women don't want to be abused and
trafficked and also they support Elon
who is also another [ __ ] creep well
it is true he likes to trade horses for
hand jobs and he's a liar he's a [ __ ]
liar which is a theme on the right which
brings us to our winner of bonehead of
the week the Liars of the Liars of the
Liars really he's just he's just a
republican he's just any old average
Republican gave Sanchez George Santos
um fits the profile exactly he lies a
lot he lies about himself he lies about
his pedigree he lies about his race he
lies about his religion he lies I mean
he lies about his
cancer and non-cancer his mom has died
at least four or five times yeah I mean
this guy listen there's gonna be a
Netflix I told you I was like there's
gonna be a Netflix
docu-series oh wow like you know there's
like how to make a murderer it's like
how to make a I don't even know what he
is what the [ __ ] well here's like a
candidate like where's the [ __ ]
when a political party a major political
party especially in in a in a democracy
like the United States of America puts a
pathological liar like Donald Trump in
charge of their party and not only in
charge of their party but in charge of
the entire country
it begins to make people think that they
can get I mean anyone can be present
either in a pathological liar and it
really does appear that George Santos
has a real major problem with lying and
it's not just like one line it's like
he'll lie about having this and then
he'll lie about not having this right
he'll lie he'll just he'll he'll when he
gets caught in a lie then he lies to get
caught out of that lie right and then
you find out later that he was lying
about that other lie to cover up for
that other lie which was covering up
from that original eye which was based
on another lie but Gabe Sanchez isn't
this just trumpism though I mean I mean
you know everyone wants him to resign
and I've been very vocal about this this
week I do not want George Santos to sign
I want George Santos to have to serve
every single [ __ ] day of his term and
I want the entire country to look at him
and go he's a Republican and this all
makes sense because I said when he was
outed as a fraud I said
uh I believe it was on Tuesday
I said that George Santos I want George
Santos to go to the floor of the house I
want him to tell and tell the American
people into a microphone the same old
lies that Republicans tell every [ __ ]
day on the house floor as if Republicans
aren't lying on our official record of
Our House of Representatives give me a
[ __ ] break I want him to go down
there and lie into a microphone because
then then just maybe people in this
country will call into question when
they watch George Santos who is an
absolute known liar even Republicans
don't want him to lie the only reason
why he hasn't kicked out on his asses
because Kevin McCarthy needs him to
become speaker that is the reason why
George Santos even exists in the
conversation still is because Kevin
McCarthy needs 218 and the LIE the lie
that he doesn't need George Santos is
even a bigger lie than George Santos has
ever told and here's why I don't want
him to resign okay I want them to own it
every single bit of it I want us to form
a narrative around it and I want every
single Republican to be tied to George
Santos and wear him like a badge like
the fake ass Herschel Walker badge which
was a lie it's all lies George Santos is
not different George Santos is not
special he doesn't tell special lies he
doesn't say them in a special way he
just got caught doing it and everyone is
grossed out by the way that he is lying
but it is not a a non-republican thing
so I don't want him to resign here's the
great part about when I said I want him
to go to the floor of the house that
night on Tucker Carlson's White
Privilege tonight the show Tulsi gambard
she was a guest host
and she said on that show after I said
that that morning that morning I said
that I want him to go to the house floor
she questioned him how in the world can
this country trust you when you go to
the house floor and speak and tell lies
on the house floor Tulsi gabbard asked
George Santos that question that night
and that's the most important thing
that's why Republicans want his vote for
218 but they don't want to be associated
with him
I'm going to disagree with you well I
figured you would I don't think that he
will and I don't want him
to resign okay
but what I do want
is I want him to be
because right now he's being
investigated by a Republican
a republican guys okay just understand
it's so there are some people in the
Republican Party who are like ah this
ain't looking so good for us and other
people are like ah we just gotta shut up
that's why Margaret Taylor green is so
adamant and so defensive
of George Santos because she again
needs right uh Kevin McCarthy to be
speaker too so that he can deliver on
his promise Taylor green so she's he's
using her as a little mini whip to like
her [ __ ] border collie to get the
cows and sheep kind of her together
right
I don't want him to resign what I feel
like would be more embarrassing yeah
would be let's say that he does because
obviously you know we've got four days
until he actually gets sworn in yeah we
see the first Kevin McCarthy vote which
he'll lose right
I want him to be arrested I want him to
go on trial and I want him to uh and
maybe he maybe he avoids those things
that he just pleads guilty to the
charges that they find on him because
here's the thing there's a whole
financial side and it's a big big
boo-boo that he's got to fix and he's
ain't fixing that [ __ ] well here's the
thing and that's why I think I don't
want him to resign because that's too
easy of a cop-out that maybe he resigns
while he's under investigation or gets
arrest or something like that but I
don't know I think I want like my
personal opinion is I don't want him to
resign because I think that's too easy
what I want him to do because here's the
thing he's going to resign if he resigns
he'll make up some BS response and say
oh the reason I resigned is because I've
got another brain tumor
The Matrix is after me oh my god well
here's the thing here's the thing the
real problem that George Santos has and
the real the biggest lie that he's told
is that he took Russian money in his
campaign right and you cannot it is
completely illegal and they will figure
you out if you take foreign money and
put it into your campaign and the seven
hundred thousand dollars that he
influxed into his campaign after not
making that much money is a real problem
for him and it's not it's not the LIE he
told about it it's the truth about it
that's where he's in real trouble here
is with the truth he can lie about a
brain tumor and his mom died at 9 11.
all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ] lying about
his school lying about where he's worked
he can lie about all that [ __ ] that's
not criminal but the truth the truth of
his crimes will get him and that is why
George Santos is our bonehead of the
week Gabe Sanchez let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all right that's bonehead of the week if
you want to vote for bonehead week every
single week on Thursday go to Tony
Michaels podcast the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube subscribe go to the
community tab
click the community tab you'll see the
poll there every single week if you're
watching us on Midas Touch also
subscribe there but come over to our
Channel And subscribe so you can vote if
you have a Twitter account you can
follow us at the Tony Michaels POD at
Tony Michaels pod you can vote there on
Twitter every single week and you can
download every single episode of
bonehead of the week on Sundays Apple
Spotify do your favorite directory make
sure to follow us subscribe and leave us
a great review while you're there every
single Friday because we do bonehead of
the week every single Friday here on the
Tony Michaels podcast the minus touch
Network Abe Sanchez
it's been one hell of a bone-headed week
and this is bone of the week everyone
stick around if you're on the podcast I
have a few announcements right after the
music
[Music]
[Applause]
bonan of the week
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week the final bonehead of the Year
final this is episode 300 300. and we
are at three hours don't give Amanda any
ideas Amanda is always telling us go to
three hours go to three hours episode
300.30 is three hours starting 2023 oh
my God there's gotta be some kind of Q
Anon thing that's going on with the what
do you call it what is the thing where
they add up the numbers and the Gematria
is that what they call it yeah something
like the mantri or some [ __ ] like that
there's got to be some kind of
conspiracy theory going yeah degrees
three hours 320 23. it's all something
going on yeah there's something there I
know I know I want to make an
announcement and it has been a great
year I hope you guys have a safe
and happy New Years for this uh weekend
it is on a weekend so there's probably
some shenanigans that can go on yeah
stay safe that's right stay safe and I
want to get I want everyone to give love
to our moderators in their chat they
have done a great job this year
um they have worked so hard they are the
greatest moderators in the world for the
greatest audience in the world MJ one of
our great moderators has a new job so
she'll be she'll be in and out
so um when you see her tell her hi and
congratulate her on the new job we are
excited that MJ is um she she her her
Situation's changing so she'll be
modding Boris while she can so that's
why you see some of the new moderators
um but but uh I want you to think and
give love to all the moderators wish
them a happy New Years and audience you
be saved you have a happy New Year
please please please come back and visit
us next week we will be on Tuesday Gabe
Sanchez we're going to be off for the
New Year's holiday I gotta recover I'm
gonna be hungover as [ __ ] yeah I know
it's still I'm still working over here
I'm gonna be wasted I'm gonna control my
alcoholic intake no don't do that you
know I like doing that while I have
covid I have some drinks I fear that if
you infuse the alcohol into you can get
rid of the cook because alcohol gets rid
of I'm hearing is that maybe if there's
like a light you could get underneath
your skin oh like I like a strobe light
you know like party po okay I was just
gonna be like bleach oh well I hear that
works not too
um so everyone pleasing on Jake bleach
um for a covet cure everyone have a
happy have a safe New Year's we'll see
you on Tuesday
same time same place Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon